Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich sage hallo.
Hier ist die 121.
Ausgabe von UKW, eurem Krisen-Podcast, der sich weiterhin vornehmlich in der
Mangelung anderer Krisen, nein,
es gibt genug Krisen, aber wir konzentrieren uns hier nach wie vor auf den Ukraine-Konflikt
und nach einem Monat kehren wir mal wieder die Scherben zusammen. Ich sage Hallo zu Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, ein Monat ist vergangen und wir wollen mal versuchen, ein wenig die Situation zu beschreiben.
Man kann sagen, dass sich insgesamt nicht viel getan hat, aber es gibt entscheidende
neue Entwicklungen, die dafür sorgen könnten, dass sich demnächst mal wieder
mehr tut in der ganzen Angelegenheit.
Da wollen wir heute darauf eingehen. Das heißt, wir wollen uns die militärische
Situation nochmal anschauen, also kurz beschreiben, wie sieht es jetzt eigentlich
aus im Krieg als solchen.
Dann wollen wir ganz speziell die Situation in den USA nochmal beschreiben,
also mal einen Rückblick machen. Wir haben das so in den letzten Folgen immer
so ein bisschen im Außenspiegel beobachtet und erwähnt, dass es da nicht vorangeht.
Jetzt gab es ja die Entscheidung, dass die USA jetzt dann doch mal wieder in
den Unterstützungsfinanztopf greifen.
Also wollen wir mal kurz schauen, warum hat es eigentlich so lange gedauert
und was hat sich denn jetzt eigentlich geändert. hat.
Dann wollen wir auch noch mal ein wenig auf die europäische Perspektive schauen, die ja immer.
Sehr divers ist und wo ich aber auch den Eindruck habe, dass sich da mittlerweile langsam was tut.
Dann nochmal so ein paar politische Details aus der Perspektive der Ukraine.
Und da jetzt auf verschiedenen Ebenen neue Militärtechnik eine Rolle spielt,
wollen wir das auch nochmal beleuchten, weil diese ganzen technischen Entwicklungen
sind tatsächlich sehr wichtig. Warum?
Weil natürlich jetzt dieser riesige Konflikt auch wie jeder Krieg so ein technisches
Wettrennen ist und man hat so den Eindruck,
alle drei Monate ändern sich die generellen Vorzeichen und es hat eben einfach
sehr viel mit der Anwendung von Technologie zu tun und deswegen ist es auch
nochmal wert, da drauf zu schauen.
Ja, ich hoffe, ich habe nichts vergessen.
Dann würde ich sagen, fangen wir mal an mit unserer militärischen Situation.
Ja, also wovon ist die Situation geprägt? Also wir hatten ja zuletzt eigentlich immer diese Situation,
es gab die ukrainische Offensive im letzten Sommer, die ist dann irgendwann
zum Stehen gekommen, Einfach weil die Ukraine nicht die Mittel hatte,
um eine total eingegrabene russische Streitmacht in irgendeiner Form nennenswert zu überrollen.
Minenfelder, aber eben auch nach wie vor diese Lufthoheit mit Hubschraubern.
Also es gab sehr viele technische Faktoren, die einfach dagegen gesprochen haben,
dass die Ukraine mehr Fortschritt machen kann.
Dann sind sie mehr oder weniger in die Verteidigungsstellung gegangen und dadurch,
dass einfach seit Oktober in den USA keine neuen Beschlüsse gefasst wurden für
eine weitere militärische Unterstützung,
lief die bis dahin zugesagte militärische Unterstützung der USA so im Januar
und Februar langsam aus.
Es wurde immer weniger und auch weil es eben keine nennenswerten weiteren Versprechungen
gab, musste dann eben auch die Ukraine anders haushalten.
Und das hat glaube ich auch dazu geführt, dass eben sehr viel Munition zurückgehalten
wurde und man eben nur so das verschossen hat, was jetzt irgendwie nötig war.
Aber das hat dann eben dazu geführt, dass die Ukraine in zunehmendem Maße in
die Defensive geriet, also nicht nur die Defensive halten konnte,
sondern sich eben in zunehmendem Maße russischer Offensiven ausgesetzt sah,
der sie eine Weile lang noch gut standhalten konnte.
Aber dann durch den Fall in Avdivka und Durchbrüchen auch an zwei,
drei anderen Stellen der Frontline musste die Ukraine jetzt immer mehr Territorium wieder hergeben.
Das ist insgesamt alles noch nicht viel. Ja, insgesamt sind die Russen so in
den letzten Monaten, je nachdem wohin man schaut, mal so 10,
20 Kilometer vorangekommen.
Nur es ist natürlich generell schlecht,
wenn die Ukraine insbesondere so Stellungen preisgeben muss,
wo sie sich eigentlich so tief eingegraben haben, dass es da für die Russen
nicht weitergehen sollte.
Derzeit gibt es vor allem zwei Orte, wo es kritisch ist.
Das eine ist halt eben der Bereich, wo sich die Ukraine zurückgezogen hat nach
dem Fall von Avdivka. Da wollte man
dann eben entlang einer Flusslinie im Wesentlichen die Stellung halten.
Jetzt ist es aber den Russen gelungen im Norden einen Durchbruch zu erzielen,
so entlang einer Eisenbahnlinie.
Das sieht gerade nicht so gut aus, also es ist gerade etwas unklar,
wann der Vorstoß der Russen dort gebremst werden kann und ob.
Das heißt, da gibt es jetzt S-Respeak gerade wirklich Geländegewinde.
Das Ganze allerdings wie immer bei den Russen unter sehr hohen Verlusten.
Also die Russen müssen einfach täglich zu hunderten Personal opfern,
um diese Fortschritte zu machen.
Gerade weil die Primärstrategie der Ukraine halt ist im Wesentlichen mit Flugdrohnen dagegen zu halten.
Das kostet die einfach eine Menge Personal, das kostet die auch eine Menge an Gerät,
also es werden nach wie vor sehr große Zahlen von Panzern, von gepanzerten Infanteriefahrzeugen
etc., Truppentransportern,
Logistikfahrzeugen, also es wird einfach nach wie vor enorm viel Material verballert.
Und Russland hat da auch mehr Verluste, als sie auch nur ansatzweise nachproduzieren
können, aber noch reicht es irgendwie.
Noch können sie aus ihren Reserven immer mehr nach vorne schieben und machen das halt auch einfach.
Und da eben der Ukraine vor allem die Artillerie ausgegangen ist,
also die Möglichkeit einfach direkt dann auch auf angreifende Truppen zu schießen,
beziehungsweise im Hinterland vielleicht auch eben von vornherein schon mal
zu verhindern, dass es Verdichtung gibt,
weil das einfach alles weggefallen ist, kommen jetzt eben diese Fortschritte
und es ist eben jetzt nicht klar, wie gut die ukrainische Armee hier funktioniert.
Und es gibt offensichtlich auch ein Personalproblem, dazu kommen wir dann später
auch nochmal. Der andere Ort, wo es gerade sehr bedrohlich ist, ist Chassiv-Yar.
Chassiv-Yar ist eine kleinere Stadt westlich von Bachmut.
Bachmut, der Ort, wo die große, also nach Avdivka mittlerweile die zweitgrößte
Schlacht dieses Krieges gelaufen ist.
Bachmut war ja selber jetzt kein großer strategischer Gewinn,
weil es in der Niederung lag.
Chassiv-Yar ist jetzt sozusagen im Westen der Ort, der auf einer Anhöhe liegt
und würden die Russen sich dieses Ortes bemächtigen können,
dann wäre das dann eben so ein ganz kritisches Einfallstor im Hinblick darauf,
dass mit Konstantin Nivka und Kramatorsk da wichtige Zentralen des ukrainischen
Widerstands dann so auf der nächsten Liste stehen würden.
Also gerade Kramatorsk war schon immer so das Zentrum des Widerstands im Donetsk.
Ja und abgesehen von ein paar kleineren Scharmützeln hier und da sind das jetzt
eigentlich gerade so die kritischen Bereiche.
Also Russland will ja Donetsk komplett für sich einnehmen und schreitet eben
jetzt hier gerade mal voran, eben weil einfach die Ukrainer nichts gegenhalten können.
Wobei man dann aber auch sagen muss, wenn man jetzt so eine Karte von der Gesamt-Ukraine hat,
ist es kaum sichtbar im Maßstab jetzt, aber trotzdem natürlich bedrohlich.
Also wir reden jetzt, der eine russische Brückenkopf ist jetzt 23 Kilometer
von der 2014er Frontlinie entfernt.
Also Salif Novo Aleksandrivka und Schasif Yahr.
Also nach dem Fall von Bachmut ist die Front jetzt zehn Kilometer weitergezogen.
Ich meine, 10 Kilometer ist jetzt nicht nichts, aber im größeren Zusammenhang
der Dinge jetzt erstmal noch nichts Schlimmes.
Aber wie du schon gesagt hast, das kann sich natürlich ändern.
Aber so ein Zusammenbruch steht glaube ich jetzt noch nicht unmittelbar bevor.
Vorher allerdings, ja, ist es bedrohlich und die Vermutung ist auch mal wieder jetzt im Westen,
dass dieser hohe Druck auch im
Hinblick mal wieder auf die jährlichen Zweite-Weltkriegs-Jubiläumsfeiern,
Dann die große Militärparade,
dass da bis dahin wieder irgendwie was präsentiert werden soll.
Am 9. Mai ist das dann, glaube ich.
Ja, 9. glaube ich, genau. Und alle warten natürlich drauf, wie jetzt die Parade
aussehen wird, nachdem die letzten Jahre das so ein bisschen armselig war.
Und man wohl jetzt aber auch keine Überflüge machen will oder beim letzten Mal
kaum Flugzeuge zu sehen waren und ein alter Panzer oder so...
Also ja, deswegen wartet man jetzt, was denn Putin dort jetzt auffahren lässt.
Wird jetzt nicht ausschließen, dass sie da jetzt dann vielleicht gucken und
ein riesen Propagandading versuchen, aber alle warten drauf,
so jetzt zu sehen, was da kommt.
Ja, generell lässt sich auch schwer einschätzen, wie viel Zug in der ganzen Sache drin ist.
Also man sieht immer wieder das Pattern, dass die Russen sich so einen Schwerpunkt
aussuchen, der manchmal militärische Gründer hat, manchmal eher so ein bisschen
politisch getrieben zu sein scheint.
Und dann wird eben für eine Zeit lang alles da reingegeben, nur so ein Tempo
lässt sich halt auch von den Russen nicht beliebig hochhalten.
Also irgendwann fehlen dir einfach die Fahrzeuge, fehlen dir die Truppen,
irgendwann ist deine Logistik auch so in die Länge gezogen.
Gerade jetzt mit diesen jüngsten Vorstößen da hinter Avdivka auf diesen Ort da, Occeretüne.
Klar, da sind sie dann mal vorangekommen, aber das muss ja dann auch alles immer
wieder versorgt werden.
Also irgendwann konsolidiert sich das automatisch.
Trotzdem insgesamt hat einfach die Tatsache, dass die Front nicht mehr hält,
schon für eine Menge Unruhe gesorgt. Insbesondere in Europa.
Wobei aber in Europa das halt dann eher so zur Folge hat, dass alle die Hände
hochhalten und sagen, oh Gott, was, wie wirklich?
Damit war jetzt aber nicht zu rechnen.
Und dann kommen mal wieder Dinge ein wenig in Bewegung.
Generell hat aber Europa einfach das Problem, dass selbst da,
wo eben schon reagiert wurde, also wo Militärproduktion hochgefahren wurde etc.,
es halt einfach dauert, bis der Zug da wirklich mal auf Geschwindigkeit kommt.
Ja, also Punkt ist, man kann vielleicht zusammenfassen,
dass Russland versucht auszunutzen, dass die Ukraine noch immer an Nachschubproblemen
leidet und versucht jetzt, solange das nicht behoben ist,
so viel Fortschritte zu machen wie möglich.
Macht aus russischer Sicht zumindest auch Sinn, das auszunutzen gerade,
weil Nachschub ist unterwegs.
Aber das kann halt noch jetzt Wochen und Monate dauern, bis sich das alles wieder normalisiert hat.
So bis da, bis wirklich Waffen und Pistole,
Munition wirklich überall dann wieder angekommen sind, wo sie gebraucht werden.
Das geht halt leider nicht von einem Tag auf den anderen, obwohl schon man jetzt
gesehen hat, dass größere Transportkolonnen in Bewegung gesetzt wurden.
Also es gab da so ein Video von einem Russen,
der so auf der deutschen Autobahn unterwegs war und dann so eine Kolonne von
Bradley-Kampffahrzeugen auf Tiefladern überholt hat und so ein bisschen dann in Panik geriet,
als er panisch kommentierte,
wie lang diese Kolonne ist.
Also insofern, da ist was schon in Gang gesetzt worden.
Aber man kann nicht einfach Schnipp machen und alles ist vor Ort, wo es gebraucht wird.
Sondern das wird noch jetzt Wochen und an einigen Stellen wahrscheinlich Monate dauern.
Bis sich das normalisiert hat, die Versorgung.
Wobei vieles jetzt auch nicht unbedingt erst über den Atlantik geschoben werden muss.
Erstmal haben die Amerikaner ja ohnehin große Waffenlager überall in Europa.
Und natürlich haben sie auch schon einiges in Polen.
Diese Bauernproteste sind jetzt endlich beendet. Also es gibt keine blockierten Grenzübergänge mehr.
Das ist positiv anzumerken und es ist gerade so ein bisschen unklar,
was jetzt mit dieser europäischen Artillerie Munitionsinitiative ist.
Das ist ja alles jetzt in trockenen Tüchern. Das heißt, das Geld ist da,
die Lieferungen sollen im Prinzip laufen. Aber wo jetzt genau,
wann, wie, wo, das sagt natürlich auch keiner.
Das ist ja klar. Also man erzählt ja jetzt den Russen nicht,
was man jetzt gerade macht, mit Ausnahme Deutschlands, die immer gerne sagen,
was wir vor allem nicht machen.
Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Genau. Was halt aber auch noch sich verändert hat, ist, wir hatten ja so eine Phase, wo die...
Wo Russen fast ihre ganzen Flugzeugaktivitäten mal eingestellt haben,
nachdem es ja so zwei Wochen gab, wo die Ukraine jeden Tag mindestens ein Flugzeug abgeschossen hat.
Diese Phase ist beendet.
Dann halt einfach auch gezeigt, dass einfach die Ukraine nicht genug Flugabwehr hat.
Teilweise war es ein Mangel an Munition, aber insgesamt kann man auch sagen,
für den breiten Angriff, den die Russen dort auf der Ebene schieben,
hat einfach Ukraine zu wenig Luftabwehrsystem.
Und sie haben halt klar gesagt, Leute,
wir brauchen hier mindestens, also mindestens noch sieben Patriots, um überhaupt erstmal
über die Runden zu kommen und so lange wird das hier weitergehen,
dass hier unsere Fabriken, unsere
Kraftwerke vor allem und teilweise auch jetzt wieder Heritage Sites,
also Angriffe auf Odessa und es wird einfach so viel über die Luft angegriffen von den Russen.
Dass diese Patriot-Raketen oder die Patriot-Systeme nicht mehr an der Front genutzt werden können,
um jetzt auch gegen diese Flugzeuge vorzugehen, sondern man konzentriert sich
komplett nur auf die Fernstreckenraketen, die sonst auf dem Land niedergehen
und selbst das gelingt halt derzeit nicht, das alles fernzuhalten.
Und deswegen könnten halt die Russen mit ihrer Luftwaffe wieder näher ran und
das kombiniert mit diesen Gleitbombs, die sie in großer Zahl zum Einsatz bringen,
haben wir ja auch schon darüber berichtet,
also 500 Kilo Bomben, die aus großer Entfernung von der Front abgeworfen werden können,
weil halt die mit den entsprechenden Kampfflugzeugen in großer Höhe abgeworfen
werden und die segeln dann sozusagen ins Ziel.
Damit sind eben die Frontstellungen der Ukrainer halt kategorisch so zerstört worden.
Also man hat einfach so viele dicke fette Bomben da über diese Methode reingeworfen,
dass sie sich halt irgendwann zurückziehen mussten.
Und genau das hat eben jetzt diese Fortschritte ermöglicht.
Wenn es also jetzt gelingt, mehr Flugabwehrsysteme wieder in Stellung zu bringen,
dann kann das eben auch die Front stabilisieren und eben dann im Idealfall auch
dazu führen, dass man mal wieder mehr Flugzeuge abgeschossen bekommt,
weil das ist derzeit Russlands größte Waffe, beziehungsweise das war im gesamten
Krieg schon immer ihr Problem,
dass sie diese Lufthoheit so nie hatten.
Davon sind ja eigentlich alle ganz am Anfang ausgegangen. Ja,
Russland wird Lufthoheit haben und dann war es das mit der Ukraine.
Und das ist ja immer verhindert worden. Und jetzt gilt es eben,
durch weitere Luftabwehrsysteme erstmal wieder Parität herzustellen.
Und dann werden wir nachher nochmal drüber reden, vor allem mit neuen Kampfflugzeugen,
mit den F-16-Kampfflugzeugen dann entsprechend gegenzuhalten.
Gut, schließen wir vielleicht die militärische Situation nochmal ab,
vor allem auch nochmal mit einem Blick auf die Situation im Schwarzen Meer.
Da haben wir ja schon mehrfach betont, dass eigentlich durch diese ganzen Seedrohnen
die Ukraine es eigentlich geschafft hat, die Russen zu besiegen.
Also während es auf dem Land schwierig ist, kann man eigentlich sagen,
Ukraine hat jetzt den Kampf im Schwarzen Meer gewonnen.
Das drückt sich unter anderem daran aus, dass jetzt die restlichen verbleibenden
Kriegsschiffe abgezogen werden.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das schon komplett erfolgt ist und ob es nicht teilweise
auch eine Finte ist, aber die haben einfach das Problem, dass sie selbst in
den russischen Häfen im Schwarzen Meer nicht mehr sicher sind.
Also die waren einfach nicht mehr in der Lage diese Schiffe zu verteidigen gegen
diese Seedrohnen und es gibt jetzt den Beschluss, dass die ins Kaspische Meer abgezogen werden.
Also da gibt es übers Asowsche Meer, gibt es dann über den Don,
kann man mit Kanälen rüber zur Volga und damit kommt man bis zum Kaspischen
Meer. Ja, also da gibt es halt eine entsprechende Verbindung.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob es für bestimmte Schiffe da eine Größenbegrenzung gibt.
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie alles abziehen können,
aber im Prinzip ist es so, alles rette sich, wer kann.
Also sie haben einfach gemerkt, dass sie können da einfach mit der Marine nichts
mehr ausrichten und es bleibt natürlich nach wie vor die Bedrohung durch Submarines
und natürlich alles was aus der Luft kommt.
Also mit Raketen kann natürlich nach wie vor eine Gefährdung des Seeverkehrs
hergestellt werden, aber man hört wenig davon.
Also es findet vielleicht nicht so viel statt, weil die Redereien keinen Bock
haben auf den potenziellen Verlust oder weil Versicherungen zu teuer sind etc.
Oder weil du auch einfach kein Personal findest für diese Schiffe.
Aber im Prinzip ist der Seekorridor wieder hergestellt worden und die Russen
können also mit ihren normalen Schiffen nichts mehr ausrichten.
Sie haben halt noch diese Submarines, ich weiß nicht wie viele es sind,
4, 5 oder so U-Boote, die sie im Schwarzen Meer haben.
Aber letzter Streich der Ukraine war, dass sie das älteste...
Noch im Einsatz befindliche Kriegsschiff der Welt, glaube ich.
Das war irgendwie noch aus dem Ersten Weltkrieg oder so.
Könnte sogar 19. Jahrhundert gewesen sein.
Anfang 20. Jahrhundert war es. Auf jeden Fall uralt und ist halt immer mal wieder
umgebaut worden. Da fragt man sich, okay, wozu kann man sowas gebrauchen?
Das ist irgendwie so ein langes Schiff mit vielen Kränen drauf.
Und das ist so ein Schiff, was geeignet ist, um U-Boote zu bergen.
Also wenn jetzt so ein U-Boot irgendwie nicht auftauchen kann oder sonst wie
beschädigt ist, dann konnte dieses Schiff dafür verwendet werden und das hat
die Ukraine sich halt irgendwie auch noch gemobst.
Also einfach, um die Situation auch für die U-Boote sehr schwer zu machen.
Ich glaube, in so einen Trocken-Dock trauen die sich derzeit auch nicht so richtig.
Also das ist alles ein bisschen unklar, wie da die Situation ist,
aber grundsätzlich kann man sagen, der Siegkrieg wurde gewonnen und der Landkrieg steht noch aus.
So viel vielleicht zur militärischen Situation. Habe ich noch irgendwas vergessen, Pavel?
Nö, ich muss sagen, ich hatte gerade nur noch mal einen Blick auf Marine Traffic
geworfen und da sind ja so eine Handvoll Schiffe vor Odessa,
so Frachter, die, also ein bisschen passiert da gerade,
wobei halt auch unklar ist,
vielleicht haben nicht alle Schiffe ihr AES, ihre Transponder an.
Und ja, es ist aber deutlich weniger Schiffsverkehr als jetzt auf der russischen
Seite so durchs Asowsche Meer und zum Asowschen Meer.
Aber ja, trotzdem fahren da Schiffe auch nach Odessa und wieder zurück.
Ja, ich war ja jetzt auch ein paar Tage in Istanbul und hab mir mal so die Situation
da in Bosporus angeschaut.
Also da fährt schon so einiges hin und her, aber wohin die fuhren,
das hat sich natürlich meiner Kenntnis entzogen.
Also man konnte zwar dann auch auf Marine Traffic gucken, so ah hier dickes
Schiff, wo gehört denn das jetzt dazu,
aber was jetzt wirklich da die Destination war, das weiß ich nicht,
ob das dann immer so ohne weiteres der Wahrheit da entspricht oder ob das nicht umfilmiert wird,
aber zumindest war so einiges auch in Richtung Rumänien unterwegs,
was da vorbei fuhr, aber das ist rein anekdotische Evidenz.
Gut, dann kommen wir doch mal wie angekündigt auf diese spezifische Situation,
die sich jetzt in den USA ergeben hat.
Also wir wissen ja alle, es ist halt Wahlkampf, die Präsidentschaftswahlen stehen
an im September und es sieht halt so aus,
als ob Donald Trump gegen Biden antreten wird.
Und die Welt ist generell so ein bisschen in so einem flatterhaften Zustand,
weil natürlich alle wissen, würde Trump nochmal Präsident der USA werden,
es wäre das totale Desaster.
Und da kann man glaube ich mal wirklich vom Untergang des Abendlandes reden.
Es ist halt einfach, man will sich das gar nicht vorstellen.
Trotzdem durch die Erfolge der Republikaner bei den sogenannten Midterm Elections,
das ist ja in den USA so, dass nicht jetzt alle vier Jahre alles neu gewählt wird,
sondern die Hälfte der Sitze im Haus werden,
also immer alle zwei Jahre sind Wahlen und es wird dann immer nur die Hälfte neu gewählt.
Was ich irgendwie für ein ganz interessantes Konzept halte, aber manchmal bin
ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, weil es in der Regel
immer dazu führt, Präsident wird gewählt,
hat dann irgendwie vielleicht auch eine Mehrheit im Haus und nach zwei Jahren
sind dann wieder alle total unzufrieden, weil...
Was auch immer, ja. Und dann wird wieder die Opposition so stärker gewählt,
dass dann eben diese Mehrheit weg ist und dann muss halt für zwei Jahre der
Präsident gegen eine Mehrheit im Haus arbeiten.
Und mit Haus meine ich halt eben den Teil des Kongresses, der eben eher wie
unser Parlament ist versus des
Senates, der halt mehr so ist wie unser Bundesrat, mal so ganz allgemein.
Also im einen hast du halt zwei Mitglieder jedes Bundesstaates im Senat und
im Haus ist es halt dann eben so nach District wieder eben gewählt wird.
Aber das alles eben mit Mehrheitswahlrecht und das Ganze bei zwei Parteien,
also ist das alles immer wieder so eine sehr merkwürdige Situation,
weil am Ende in den USA im Prinzip nur eine kleine Minderheit von Staaten irgendwie
nennenswert wirklich beeinflussbar ist.
Die sogenannten Swing States, wo halt diese Mehrheiten traditionell eher zwischen
Republikanern und Demokraten hin und her schwingen, während eben so klar ist,
so Kalifornien geht an die Demokraten, New York geht an die Demokraten,
Texas geht an die Republikaner, da tut sich irgendwie nicht viel.
Aber so Ohio und Michigan und Arizona.
Es gibt halt einfach so ein paar Staaten, wo das irgendwie nicht so klar ist
und wo es einfach offen ist, wer da letzten Endes mobilisiert werden kann und
so sieht es natürlich dann auch in diesem Jahr wieder aus.
Also bei den letzten Midterm-Wahlen haben die Republikaner eine Mehrheit im
Parlament gehabt, im Haus.
Aber es lief nicht so gut, wie es normalerweise lief.
Das heißt, diese Mehrheit war sehr klein. Die betrug halt nur sieben Sitze oder
so und das hat dazu geführt, dass diese super radikalisierten Member des Hauses,
die halt alles so gewählte waren von Trumps Segen.
Also er hat ja dann immer so in der Öffentlichkeit ganz aktiv bestimmte Kandidaten unterstützt,
sodass eben nur so radikale sogenannte MAGA-Republicans da auf die Liste kamen,
dann eben gewählt wurden,
sodass man jetzt eben in dieser Hausmehrheit von sieben Sitzen …,
Ein Teil hat dieser sogenannte Freedom Caucus, also die völlig durchgetreten
und die Freedom Caucus gab es schon immer,
das waren immer schon so diese super rechten Republikaner und dann gibt es halt
nochmal so diese Reihe von völlig Bekloppten um Matt Gaetz und Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Also völlig durchgeknallte, mager Republikaner, die halt jede Verschwörungstheorie
runterbeten und denen teilweise sogar Fox News schon irgendwie nicht mehr geholfen ist.
Wobei die Mehrheit von sieben Sitzen ist aber deutlich geschrumpft.
Ich glaube sogar um vier Sitze mittlerweile.
Einmal wurde halt der Republikaner Santos aus dem Repräsentantenhaus ausgeschlossen,
weil er wegen Betrug angeklagt ist.
Und mit großer Mehrheit, also 311 von 435 Abgeordneten haben dafür gestimmt.
Aber immerhin 114 stimmten gegen seinen Ausschluss, obwohl er ja krasse Sachen gemacht hat.
Ein kompletter Hochstapler, der gelogen hat.
Und dann, ja, über seine Karriere und dann hat dann halt Spendengelder, Spendengelder, ja,
und im Wesentlichen hat er Spendengelder unterschlagen und hat dann unter anderem
eben Identitätsdiebstahl, hat dann, sagen wir mal, von Leuten,
die was gespendet haben,
glaube ich, dann auch noch von der Kreditkarte was abgebucht,
einfach ohne deren Zustimmung und solche Sachen.
Das war jedenfalls Santos. Und dann sind noch mindestens zwei Republikaner zurückgetreten,
die einfach keinen Bock mehr hatten auf MAGA.
Die einfach gestresst waren und gesagt haben, das machen sie jetzt nicht mehr mit.
Und die halt auch gesehen haben, dass sie auch keine Chance haben,
irgendwie nochmal wiedergewählt zu werden,
weil sie eben pro Ukraine und Anti-MAGA waren und dann einfach gesagt haben,
das muss ich mir nicht mehr antun mit diesen Irren hier.
Das macht man ja scheiß alleine. Zu arbeiten, genau.
Und deswegen waren es jetzt, glaube ich, nur noch drei oder ist jetzt die Mehrheit
eher nur so drei oder vier.
Was die ja auch hätten machen können ist zu sagen, ich trete jetzt komplett
bei den Republikanern aus und ich wandle mich jetzt zum Demokraten und stimme
jetzt einfach mit den anderen,
weil dann wäre ja nicht nur eine Stimme weg gewesen,
sondern dann wären es ja effektiv schon zwei gewesen.
Aber das hat meines Wissens keiner gemacht und da sieht man mal,
das fasziniert mich auch immer wieder unheimlich, also auch größte Kritiker
von Trump in der republikanischen Partei und es gibt so einige,
die einfach damit nicht leben können.
So, diese republikanische Partei dann aber zu verlassen und einfach zu sagen so, ey,
ich spiele da jetzt nicht mehr mit und ich mache jetzt einfach bei den anderen
mit, dafür reicht es dann auch nicht.
Das ist so tief, man ist so tief verwurzelt in dieser Parteikultur.
Dass die das nicht machen können.
Also der größte Schritt ist dann schon zu sagen, ich tritte bevor meine Legislatur
abläuft zurück und das tue ich dann aber auch zu einem Zeitpunkt,
wo durch die Nähe zu den nächsten Wahlen auch nicht mehr neu gewählt wird.
Wo dieser Sitz dann nicht mehr vergeben wird, wie das bei George Santos übrigens noch der Fall war.
Das heißt, George Santos ist halt weg und dafür wurde dann noch ein Demokrat
neu gewählt. So, das ist schon noch passiert.
Aber die, die jetzt zuletzt dran waren, die sind halt innerhalb dieses Schwellwerts,
wo dann der Sitz auch erstmal nicht weiter vergeben wird.
Ja, jedenfalls, wie halt ja die Situation war,
war, dass so vor Monaten bereits im Senat ein Kompromiss ausgehandelt wurde.
Das heißt, der Senat hatte dann mit Mehrheit von Republikanern und Demokraten...
Wobei im Senat haben die Demokraten eine kleine Mehrheit und die hatten halt
ein komplettes Paket vorgelegt,
was auch den Segen von beiden hatte und von beiden Seiten, Das halt ein Paket
war mit Militärhilfe für die Ukraine, Militärhilfe für Israel,
Militärhilfe für Taiwan und
Geld für die Grenze zu Mexiko und für Asylbearbeitungsverfahren und so.
Und dieser Kompromissvorschlag, der wurde von Johnson jetzt einfach nicht zur Abstimmung gestellt.
Eine Sache müssen wir an der Stelle noch kurz erläutern.
Also als dieses neue Haus sich geformt hat, also als sozusagen die Republikaner
die Mehrheit übernommen haben, dann ist es ja sozusagen deren Aufgabe,
einen neuen Sprecher zu wählen.
Und der Sprecher der Mehrheitsfraktion im Haus ist eigentlich so die zweitwichtigste
Person nach dem Präsidenten.
Er hat einfach am meisten Macht, denn nur der Sprecher bestimmt,
was überhaupt zur Abstimmung aufgestellt wird.
Und am Anfang haben sie ja diesen McCarthy gewählt und das hat ja schon,
wie viele Wahlgänge gedauert?
15 oder sowas in der Größenordnung?
Es war ein Riesendrama.
Gereicht. Und nachdem dann dieser McCarthy aus Sicht dieser Hardcore super rechtsextremen
Republicans schon den Demokraten,
zu weit entgegengekommen ist, weil er halt den.
Haushaltsbeschluss, das ist ja auch immer so ein Tauziehen, der Haushalt muss
verabschiedet werden, sonst kann die Regierung kein Geld mehr ausgeben.
Nachdem sozusagen er schon bereit war,
den Demokraten dann eben so eine temporäre Haushaltsverlängerung zu geben,
da sind die ja schon durchgedreht und dann haben die den halt weggeschickt und
dann ging es ewig weiter,
dann haben sie drei, vier, fünf andere Kandidaten verbrannt,
ich weiß nicht genau wie viele, es waren nicht fünf, aber zwei oder drei,
die dann eben keine Mehrheit bekommen haben,
bis sie sich auf diesen bis dahin noch vollkommen unbekannten Johnson geeinigt haben.
Der, seitdem er an der Macht ist, aber auch nichts auf die Kette bekommen hat.
Weil es gab einfach fast überhaupt gar kein, es wurde fast überhaupt nichts mehr gemacht.
Weil diese Einigung im Senat mit dieser Vorschlag, jetzt machen wir mal was.
Also das ganze Trump lag aber immer, ja wir müssen jetzt mal hier unsere Grenze
im Süden Mexiko, das ist ja das Wichtigste, wir können ja nicht der Ukraine
helfen, wenn wir jetzt hier unsere eigene Grenze nicht auf die Kette kriegen.
Und das waren alles solche Ablenkungsmanöver.
Dann haben sie diesen Kompromiss im Senat ausgehandelt und dann hätte eigentlich
nur noch das Haus zustimmen müssen und dann so der Johnson so,
ja nee, da müssen wir nochmal was dran ändern und so geht's ja gar nicht.
Und so ging das hin und her und dann wurde alle zwei Wochen wurde das Haus wieder
in den Urlaub verabschiedet.
Also nicht im Urlaub im Sinne von alle machen Urlaub, sondern es gibt immer
so Sitzungswochen und dann gibt es so dieses, wir fahren mal alle in unsere
Bezirke und reden mit unseren Bürgern.
Und das findet aber normalerweise nicht so oft statt, aber da war das dann die ganze Zeit.
Also es wurde die ganze Zeit so ein Hin und Her taktieren gemacht,
nur um nicht über dieses Paket abstimmen zu müssen.
War einfach offensichtlich. Und es war auch offensichtlich, was der Grund dafür
war. Der Grund war nämlich, Trump hat das alles nicht gepasst.
Er wollte vor allem nicht, dass es eine Einigung gibt mit den Demokraten über diese Grenzfrage.
Die wollten das zwar die ganze Zeit so als Popanz vor sich her tragen und sagen
so, ja, unsere Grenze und Präsident Biden findet keine Lösung,
konnte er aber auch nicht, weil das muss er eben mit dem Haus machen.
Dann gab es halt eine Einigung im Senat und dann war ihnen das aber auch nicht
gut genug, weil das hätte ja bedeutet,
dass es auf einmal eine Lösung gibt und Trump wollte halt die ganze Zeit,
dass dieses politische Thema weiterhin offen ist.
Also er war gar nicht an der Lösung interessiert, sondern er wollte halt für
seinen Wahlkampf ein Thema haben, auf dem er rumreiten kann.
Und dementsprechend wurde auch die ganze Zeit diese Ukraine Hilfe,
die ihm halt auch nicht gepasst hat, weil wir wissen es nicht,
weil Russland seine Rechnungen bezahlt oder keine Ahnung.
Also auf jeden Fall, diese Maga-Republicans waren einfach auch gegen eine Einigung
mit der Ukraine oder für die Ukraine und haben halt die ganze Zeit diese russischen
Talking Points bedient.
Das ging schon so weit, dass also diese Marjorie Taylor Greene,
diese völlig durchgeknallte aus diesem Maga-Teil, dann irgendwann in den letzten
Wochen hat sich dann so der Spitzname Moskau Marjorie für sie eingebürgert.
So krass war das schon so und dann merkte man schon langsam,
jetzt kippt die Sache langsam.
Also es war einfach, selbst bei den Republikanern war so dieses so,
Leute, hört ihr euch mal hier die Security Briefings ab, so die Ukraine verliert
gerade gegen die Russen und es gibt einfach dann noch genug Republikaner,
denen das dann irgendwie alles auch zu weit ging.
Und Trump hin, Trump her, Wahlen hin und her.
Ich habe so den Eindruck gehabt, es war so langsam der Punkt erreicht,
wo die dann doch mehr so dieses Country over Party wiederherstellen wollten.
Also irgendwann haben sie auch gemerkt, dass sie dem Land schaden,
wenn die Russen in der Ukraine weiter Fortschritte erzielen.
Ja, also es kam zunehmend weniger gut an in den USA, diese Blockadehaltung sicherlich.
Und was dann aber kam, was glaube ich das Fass zum Überlaufen gebracht hat,
war dann die Eskalation zwischen Israel und Iran.
Waren, die ja begonnen hat.
Gut, ich meine, wo fängt man da an? Weil eigentlich...
Es folgte irgendwie mal Reaktion auf Reaktion, aber vielleicht kann man mal sagen,
wir haben beim letzten Mal auch kurz drüber geredet, dass ja Israel Konsulat
in Syrien, in Damaskus bombardiert hat.
Und hochrangige iranische Generäle unter anderem und Botschaftskonsulat,
Personal, also ich glaube zehn Tote oder so.
Und daraufhin hat dann der Iran
mit einem angekündigten größeren Raketen-Cruise-Missile-Angriff reagiert.
Und der aber wenig Schaden in Israel verursacht hat,
weil der auch mit Ansage kam und dann unter anderem auch alle möglichen anderen
Länder mitgeholfen haben.
Bei der Raketenabwehr Amerikaner, Engländer, aber auch Jordanien.
Also jedenfalls wurde fast alles abgeschossen, was der Iran dort auf Israel abgefeuert hat.
Aber ein paar ballistische Raketen sind durchgekommen.
Fünf, glaube ich.
Ja, fünf und haben irgendwo einen Flugplatz im Wesentlichen getroffen.
Aber auch von Israelischen Opfern wurde nicht berichtet.
Ich glaube, ein Mädchen ist irgendwo.
Ja, aber nicht in Israel. Wo war das? Das war in Jordanien, glaube ich.
Ah, okay.
Ja.
Und dann wurde halt plötzlich jetzt schon so wurde dritte Weltkrieg Szenarien
an die Wand gemalt und alle warteten dann darauf, was macht Israel jetzt?
Also geht das Ganze jetzt in einen massiven Krieg zwischen Israel und Iran über
so und ist das vielleicht der Auftakt dann zu einem dritten Weltkrieg.
Und ja, dann verging glaube ich dann fast eine Woche so,
bis dann die israelische Reaktion auf den iranischen Angriff erfolgte und die
fiel doch deutlich kleiner aus,
als alle das erwartet hatten.
Also Israel hat ein paar Raketen irgendwie durchgekriegt und ja.
Das war es dann und danach ging dann auch der Ölpreis wieder runter und so wie
es aussieht, hat sich das dann jetzt erstmal beruhigt.
Ich meine, das Problem ist, dass Israel und Iran auch erwähnt,
dass sie beide Probleme haben,
gegeneinander Krieg zu führen, weil da halt ein Haufen anderer Länder dazwischen
liegen und sie sich eigentlich nur aus der Ferne beschießen können.
Und weder auf dem See noch auf dem Landweg irgendwie da näher aneinander rankommen.
Und ich glaube, dass dann auch die USA massiv Druck gemacht haben auf Israel und gesagt haben, okay,
wir haben euch zwar geholfen, jetzt die Raketen abzufangen, Aber wenn ihr jetzt
anfangt, so auf den Iran, also das,
was ihr auf den Iran verballert, wissen wir nicht, ob, wann und wie wir euch das ersetzen können.
Das kann dauern. Ihr wisst, es ist jetzt viel Bedarf gerade weltweit an Militär-Hardware.
Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass dann der Israel auch gesagt hat,
okay, das ist uns hier doch dann ein bisschen zu kritisch.
Und sowieso, also die größte Gefahr eigentlich für Israel geht wahrscheinlich
von der Hezbollah aus, die so 150.000...
Kurzstrecken-Raketen hat alle nicht besorgt, aber wenn die alle abgefeuert werden,
dann kann man schon sicher sein, dass Israel wehtun würde.
Und auch die Hisbollah hat sich da doch deutlich zurückgehalten.
Die haben zwar auch ein bisschen dann mitgespielt, aber in keinem nennenswerten Umfang.
Das ist eh ganz interessant zu sehen, wie da so taktiert wird und wie man fast
schon erwartbare Strikes ausführt.
Also die Antwort der Israelis war ja, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe.
Schon ein gezielter Cruise Missile Angriff und ich meine es ist berichtet worden,
dass dabei so ein S-400 System kaputt gemacht wurde.
Also das hat schon weh getan, bringt jetzt den Iran nicht um,
war aber auf der anderen Seite auch so eine klare Ansage mit,
eure Luftabwehr kriegt unsere Sachen nicht abgeschossen.
Aber wir haben von euch alles abgeschossen, bis auf diese paar Dinger,
warum auch immer das schief gegangen ist, weiß man nicht.
Aber eigentlich ist der komplette iranische Angriff ist so komplett weggegangen
und das war auch glaube ich nicht, dass sie davon ausgegangen sind,
dass sie mit allem durchkommen,
aber ich glaube sie hatten schon die Hoffnung, dass sie bei diesen 200-300 Raketen mehr erwischen.
So, nicht, dass sie nennenswert irgendwas zu zerstören, aber dass das so nahezu
komplett zu 98 Prozent vom Himmel geholt wurde,
das war dann auch dem Iran so ein bisschen peinlich und sie sind ja dann auch
im arabischen Raum auch ordentlich an der Nase, in sozialen Medien so an der
Nase herumgezogen worden so für die Performance.
Naja, dann haben die Israelis halt nochmal so einmal nachgetreten,
so einmal so einen gezielten Tritt in die Eier sozusagen, aber dann auch ruhig gehalten.
Und darauf wolltest du es ja hinaus...
Das Endergebnis war, der Iran greift massiv Israel an.
Und jetzt müssen wir mal wieder den Blick auf die amerikanische Innenpolitik legen.
Israel ist nach wie vor einer der stärksten Verbündeten der USA.
Und Israel ist vor allem mit diesem, wie hieß diese Gruppe?
APEC.
APEC. Das ist, sagen wir mal, einer der größten Finanzierer der amerikanischen
Politik und auch einer der größten Finanzierer der Republikaner.
Also das ist sozusagen etwas, dem die sich nicht entziehen können.
Eine massive Lobbyorganisation und Biden hatte ja ganz klar dann auch gesagt,
oder die Demokraten hatten dann klar gesagt, dass sie halt nur einem Komplettpaket zustimmen würden.
Also die Republikaner hatten das aber als Grund genommen, dann zu sagen,
nein, wenn über ein Komplettpaket abgestimmt wird, dann das machen wir nicht mit.
Woraufhin dann der Kompromiss war, okay, dann wird doch das Ganze in vier einzelne Dinge zerlegt.
Ich habe mich dann gefragt, wie ist denn dann jetzt garantiert,
dass auch alle vier Dinger durchkommen?
Und gut, garantiert war es jetzt nicht, aber es war auch, glaube ich,
eine klare Ansage, dass wenn nicht alles durchkommt,
dass dann Biden sein Veto einlegen wird und auch der Senat das nicht unterstützen wird. So.
Und zum Glück ist das dann auch alles so gelaufen, dass das alles beschlossen wurde jetzt.
Also alle Hilfen auch für die Ukraine, für Israel, für Taiwan und Sonstiges
und eben das Grenzpaket.
Und es wurden aber ein paar Änderungen vorgenommen und eine Änderung davon war,
dass ins Gesetz geschrieben wurde,
dass die USA Attackants liefern müssen. Das war in dem Senatsentwurf nicht mit drin.
Und dass ein Teil der Gelder, die an die Ukraine gehen, nur geliehenes Geld sind.
Wobei es dann wiederum die Einschränkung gab, dass der Präsident davon dann
aber auch einen Großteil wieder erlassen darf.
Das waren aber nur so Kleinigkeiten. Das eigentliche Versprechen,
glaube ich, was im Raum stand und was das Druckmittel auch war,
dass die Republikaner jetzt dann auch wirklich durchziehen,
ist, dass ja wiederum die Maga-Republicans, allen voran halt diese Marjorie
Taylor Greene ja schon angekündigt hat, dass wenn das dann abgestimmt wird,
dann kommt sie nochmal an und macht diese, wie hieß das nochmal gleich,
also dann will sie sozusagen den Sprecher nochmal zur Wahl stellen.
Also es ging darum, den Sprecher abzuwählen.
Also nochmal diesen ganzen Zirkus nochmal von vorne anzufangen,
der letztes Mal schon Monate gedauert hat, worauf natürlich überhaupt keiner Bock hat.
Aber dann haben halt die Demokraten gesagt, wenn das kommt, dann stimmen wir
halt für euren Sprecher und retten dem sozusagen die letzten Monate.
Hatte, weil bei der nächsten Wahl wäre es eh absehbar, dass das sozusagen zum
neuen Sprecher führen wird.
So, weil die Demokraten vielleicht gewinnen im Idealfall.
Also das war sozusagen jetzt dieses Spiel.
Was ich mich jetzt aber noch frage ist, was war letzten, also wer hat am Ende
seine Meinung dann wirklich geändert?
War es jetzt der Johnson, der ja im Prinzip die ganze Zeit den den Eindruck
gemacht hat, dass er sozusagen für Trump seine Backe dahinhält.
War es am Ende Trump selber? Waren es die beiden zusammen?
War es die Partei, die denen gesagt hat,
Das war es jetzt. Also ich frage mich, was war letzten Endes der Tipping Point?
Also der Auslöser war sicherlich dieser Raketenangriff des Irans.
Aber bei wem hat es letzten Endes zu einem Wandel der Beurteilung der Situation geführt?
Weil Johnson ist ja ab dem Moment auf einmal in die Öffentlichkeit gegangen,
als hätte er auf einmal das erste Mal davon gehört, von der ganzen Situation
und redete halt auf einmal wie so ein normaler Republikaner,
während er vorher halt die ganze Zeit wie so ein Trump-Fan geredet hat.
Dann war auf einmal Amerika wichtig und wir müssen unsere internationale Stellung
und das ist jetzt eine große Krise und Russland darf nicht gewinnen und man
fragte sich so, ist der Typ jetzt irgendwie ausgetauscht worden oder was ist jetzt gerade passiert?
Ja, ja, ja, alles sieht so aus. Bei Trump ist es so, wie bei allen Populisten,
bei allen rechten Populisten, da steckt nicht viel Ideologie dahinter.
Und der ist jederzeit, also wenn er jetzt einen Vorteil sieht,
seine Position zu ändern,
dann ändert er die auch ohne irgendwie, ja, was interessiert mich mein Gerede von gestern. Ja, so.
Und das scheint so zu sein, dass er so ein bisschen dann den Switch gemacht
hat nach dem Motto, naja, Ukraine ist wichtig und die Europäer müssen aber mehr tun.
Und so gesagt hat, aber ja, wir machen das dann jetzt, aber Ukraine ist wichtig,
aber eigentlich müssten die Europäer noch mehr tun.
Womit man leider sagen muss, er auch Recht hat.
Ja, das ist so eine der wenigen Dinge, wenn Trump sagt, die Europäer tun zu
wenig für ihre Verteidigung, dann hat er damit vollkommen recht.
Allerdings aus Sicht Europas oder aus Sicht der USA würde eine Emanzipierung Europas,
also wenn Europa jetzt militärisch aufrüstet,
würde das aber auch bedeuten am Ende, dass Europa politisch an Gewicht gewinnt gegenüber den USA.
Dass die USA dann eben, ja...
Und nicht mehr diese Position oder diesen überragenden Status plötzlich haben,
sondern dass dann sagen plötzlich Europa auch in der Lage wäre,
weltweit mehr zum Player zu werden, als das bisher der Fall ist.
Auch wenn der politische Wille und die politische Struktur bisher nicht da ist.
Aber wir haben ja jetzt viele Änderungen gesehen und in Europa ist da ja auch einiges im Schiff.
Und eigentlich wäre das fast zu begrüßen, wenn Europa global mehr an Einfluss
gewinnen würde gegenüber den USA.
Insofern wäre Trump jetzt aus meiner Sicht jetzt zwar eine Katastrophe für die USA,
was dann auch erstmal eine Katastrophe für die Welt bedeutet,
aber langfristig durchaus auch eine Chance für Europa darstellen würde.
Und auf jeden Fall hat er jetzt dazu beigetragen, auch Europa massiv aufzurütteln,
weil plötzlich auch in Europa allen klar geworden ist,
wir können uns unter Umständen nicht dauerhaft auf die USA verlassen.
Bevor wir auf Europa kommen, lass uns vielleicht die Geschichte,
die sich jetzt sozusagen in den USA abgespielt hat, kurz zu Ende bringen.
Also die Situation hat sich geändert, irgendwann war es dann auch….
Trump angekommen, dass er quasi mit dieser Haltung sich nicht mehr durchsetzen
kann. Der APEC macht Stress.
Die Öffentlichkeit war ganz klar auf der Seite der Ukraine und vor allem auf der Seite Israels.
Die beiden Fälle waren einfach verbunden und es geschah dann sozusagen das,
was man schon langsam nicht mehr für möglich gehalten hat. Es gab diese Abstimmung,
alles ist verabschiedet worden. Was ist verabschiedet worden?
Es ist ein Paket von 60 Milliarden US-Dollar verabschiedet worden,
was sich jetzt sozusagen für
das nächste halbe Jahr, ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie lange, erstreckt.
Im Prinzip ist jetzt die USA in der Lage, jede Woche ein Hilfspaket,
ein militärisches Hilfspaket in Höhe von einer Milliarde US-Dollar zu,
also es geht glaube ich über ein Jahr, also im Prinzip jedes Jahr können sie
jetzt eine Milliarde US-Dollar ausgeben.
Der Großteil dieses Geldes ist dafür gedacht, in die eigene Militärindustrie zu investieren.
Das war ja schon immer das Absurde an dieser ganzen Haltung der Republikaner,
die immer gesagt haben, kein Geld für die Ukraine.
Das ist im Wesentlichen Geld für die USA selber.
Und ein Großteil dieser Raketen und Waffen, die geschickt wurden,
beileibe nicht alles, aber wirklich sehr viel, sind Sachen, die die USA sonst
hätten teuer entsorgen müssen.
Also im Prinzip ist das das billigste Entsorgungsprogramm, was sie je hatten,
weil anstatt aufwendig irgendwelche Missiles wieder auseinanderbauen zu müssen und.
Dem Schrott zuzuführen, was auch nochmal Geld kostet, können sie stattdessen
einfach auf ein Schiff legen oder auf ein Flugzeug packen in die Ukraine und auf die Russen werfen.
So, bam, dann explodiert das und dann ist das quasi entsorgt.
Klingt jetzt ein bisschen zynisch, aber das ist ja einfach die Realität.
Das heißt, es ist nicht nur so, dass es die USA Geld kostet,
neue zu bauen, aber das hätten sie eh machen müssen.
Sicherlich gibt es ein paar Sachen, die jetzt auch schon vor Ablauf ihrer Lifetime
dort verballert werden.
Aber so oder so geht ein Großteil dieses Geldes direkt in die amerikanische
Wirtschaft und führt dazu, dass eben große Unternehmen, die halt dort Militärtechnik herstellen,
also Boeing, Raytheon, wie sie alle heißen, die bekommen halt die Kohle.
Und nur ein kleiner Teil von diesem Geld sind direkte Gelder,
die tatsächlich an die Ukraine gehen.
So und das ist jetzt beschlossen worden und jetzt sind auch die ersten Pakete
schon verabschiedet worden und wie du schon gesagt hast,
neu ist ja eben, dass auch diese Attackams mit dabei sind das heißt es ist in
diesem Beschluss eigentlich auch das erste Mal ein expliziter politischer Wunsch
kodiert weil bisher hatten wir ja immer so dieses,
ja die Ukraine darf nicht verlieren,
Das war so immer diese Formulierung mit, oder sagen wir mal so,
oder Russland darf nicht gewinnen.
Wie Roman auch immer das macht.
Aber was nie so richtig gesagt wurde ist, Russland muss verlieren.
Und es ist sicherlich noch einiges zu gehen in der Art und Weise,
wie das alles formuliert wird.
Aber man merkt, dass es langsam kippt, dass man so dieses,
ja nee, also irgendwie müssen wir Russland noch mehr einnorden und es traut
sich derzeit noch keiner zu sagen, was am Ende dieses Prozesses ohnehin stehen wird.
Und auch in Europa noch nicht so ganz.
Aber ich glaube, wir befinden uns jetzt auf dem Weg, wo man sagen kann,
in einem Jahr, spätestens in zwei Jahren, wobei ich es furchtbar finde,
dass wir über solche Zeiträume überhaupt noch reden müssen.
Aber es kann sein, dass dieser Konflikt noch zwei Jahre dauert.
Einfach weil die Russen so lange noch reinschieben können. So lange haben sie
noch Zeug, Panzer, Leute.
Du weißt, was wir zynisch in der ersten Sendung zur Ukraine geschätzt haben,
wie lange der Konflikt dauern könnte in den frühen Sendungen,
so gemessen an Afghanistan oder anderen Dingen.
Deswegen so zehn Jahre sind da jetzt nicht völlig, also das war jetzt vielleicht
nicht eine seriöse Prognose, aber zumindest war es eine Prognose.
Eine Möglichkeit.
Eine Möglichkeit oder nicht unwahrscheinlich. Und es sieht jetzt ganz so aus,
als wenn uns der Krieg auch weiterhin noch eine ganze Weile erhalten bleibt.
Also ich wäre schon ganz froh, wenn es mit den nächsten zwei Jahren dann auch getan wäre.
Ich glaube, dass in dem Moment, wo man jetzt die generelle Ausrichtung oder
Zielsetzung des Westens ändert.
Wenn man sagt, Russland muss besiegt werden und ich glaube nicht,
dass irgendein Weg daran vorbeiführt, dass wir an diesem Punkt kommen werden.
Weil dann die Logik einfach sagt, Russland muss besiegt werden,
heißt wir müssen alles dafür tun, dass Russland besiegt wird.
Und alles dafür tun, dass Russland besiegt wird, ist halt mehr als der Ukraine
genug Waffen zu schicken, dass sie ihre Front halten können.
Sondern es muss sozusagen eine aktive Änderung der Besetzungssituation herbeigeführt werden.
Und das ist etwas, was sich jetzt das erste Mal abzeichnet. Es bezeichnet sich
ab in dem Auftrag, der quasi mit diesem Beschluss in den USA jetzt erfolgt ist, weil man sagt.
Russland muss etwas entgegengesetzt werden, wir brauchen auch Attack-Ims und
wir müssen die einsetzen.
Ich bin mir jetzt noch nicht so sicher, ob damit auch schon der Nutzungsraum
dieser Attack-Ims geändert wird. Also was ja jetzt noch mit dazu kommt,
ist, dass von Long Range die Rede war.
Das ist sozusagen das Erste. Und Long Range in Bezug auf die Situation im Ukraine-Konflikt bedeutet,
wir haben derzeit diese Attack-Games-Raketen, die können so 100,
150 Kilometer abdecken.
Also das ist sozusagen derzeit der Wirkungsraum, in dem sich die Ukraine mit
den ihnen zur Verfügung stehenden und zur Verfügung gestellten Waffen derzeit betätigen könnte.
Das reicht aber nicht, um das Hinterland des besetzten Bereichs vollständig abzudecken.
Insbesondere reicht es nicht, um die Krimbrücke zu attackieren, die Kerchbrücke.
Jetzt ist aber von Long Range die Rede und wenn wir von Long Range reden,
bei dem Arsenal heißt das eben 300 Kilometer und damit kommt auf einmal das
erste Mal alles wirklich unmittelbar in Reichweite, was derzeit von Russland
besetzt ist in der Ukraine.
Und es eröffnet natürlich auch nochmal ganz andere Möglichkeiten des Rückschlags
im russischen Bereich, den man ja so auch schon erreicht,
aber wo halt bei vielen Waffenlieferungen noch diese Einschränkung war so,
ja könnt ihr haben, aber dürft ihr halt nicht auf russisches Gebiet schicken,
sondern dürft ihr nur auf besetztes Gebiet schicken.
Was natürlich ein bisschen absurd ist in so einem Krieg, wo hinter der Grenze
halt die gesamte Mobilisierungs- und Logistikinfrastruktur für den Angriff auf
das besetzte Gebiet liegt und was selbstverständlich auch mit angegriffen werden muss,
um da entsprechende Effekte zu erzielen und was ja auch absolut mit dem Völkerrecht im Einklang steht.
Also von daher ist halt leider diese ganze Diskussion auch in den USA noch zu
sehr von so einer Angst geprägt, aber ich glaube in den USA ändert sich das.
So und jetzt können wir ja mal den Move machen auf Europa,
weil ich eben auch den Eindruck habe, dass sich das in Europa langsam ändert
und wir jetzt eben so einen langsamen Bewusstseinswandel sehen,
der sich zwar in Deutschland noch nicht so richtig niederschlägt,
aber auf jeden Fall in Frankreich.
Ja, das war ja dann auch die große Debatte,
die dann bei uns aufkam, die läuft ja auch jetzt schon seit längerem,
dass Macron ins Spiel gebracht hat, französische Truppen in die Ukraine zu schicken.
Das wurde natürlich von russischer Seite aus weder interpretiert,
als dass da jetzt französische Bataillone in den Krieg ziehen.
Aber was wohl vor allem gemeint war,
war halt bestimmte Experten und Spezialisten zu schicken, die bei der Ausbildung
und bei der Bedienung bestimmter Waffensysteme helfen.
Was faktisch jetzt auch stattfindet eigentlich.
Aber eben unter prekären Bedingungen, sage ich mal.
Weil, ja, das halt eben nicht offiziell ist und deswegen es da Grenzen gibt,
was dann fremdes Militär in dem Land eigentlich machen kann und was nicht.
Und es ist dann halt alles so ein bisschen ungeklärt und findet in einer Grauzone
statt, was nicht unbedingt hilfreich ist.
Aber ich vermute auch deswegen, dass es mehr politisch war, diese Ansage,
mehr ein Signaling an Russland als jetzt tatsächlich eine...
Dass jetzt Frankreich in größerem Umfang plötzlich Truppen schickt.
Aber es hat natürlich die Diskussion aufgemacht, vor allem auf russischer Seite.
Und in Deutschland wurde dann natürlich auch die Debatte, es ist dann natürlich auch hochgekocht.
Und von der SPD ist da jetzt, glaube ich, nicht viel zu erwarten,
weil ich weiß nicht, ob du schon die neuen Plakate der SPD zur Europawahl gesehen hast.
Nee, was steht da drauf?
SPD irgendwie die Friedenspartei.
Frieden wählen oder so.
Ach ja. SPD wählen. Naja, besonnen handeln habe ich noch gelesen.
Es ist alles so eine schöne Färberei mit irgendwie, ja, wir lassen uns hier
nicht in die Konflikte reinziehen.
Ich meine, es reflektiert in gewisser Hinsicht die Die Denke,
die derzeit in Deutschland, glaube ich, in der Öffentlichkeit noch vorherrscht,
so dieses, oh ja, nee und Krieg und so, das ist ja alles ganz böse und das wollen wir ja nicht.
Und wenn wir uns nur genug wegducken und die Augen zuhalten,
dann wird das schon irgendwie weggehen.
Aber ich glaube, an dem Punkt sind wir schon lange dran vorbei.
Und die Realpolitik, die ja gemeinhin mit diesem deutschen Begriff international
auch erwähnt wird, Realpolitik findet glaube ich derzeit eher in Frankreich statt. hat.
Damit will ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass alles, was jetzt in Frankreich entschieden
wurde in der letzten Zeit und auch das Maß der Beteiligung Frankreichs an der
Unterstützung der Ukraine in irgendeiner Form angemessen und ausreichend ist.
Das mit Sicherheit nicht.
Aber die Franzosen.
Als nun mal die kräftigste Militärmacht in der EU sind definitiv auf einem anderen
Weg und Macron hat halt in seinem ersten Hinweis, ja was du erwähnt hast,
im Prinzip auch erstmal beendet dieses,
also wir hören jetzt mal auf den Russen immer zu sagen, was wir nicht tun,
sondern wir schließen mal erstmal nichts aus.
Das war ja so im Prinzip das Erste und es ging erstmal primär um,
was wäre, wenn wir unsere Leute in der Ukraine haben und helfen,
was sowieso schon der Fall ist.
Ja, das war ja das Absurde und dann hat ja Macron gesagt,
wir können nicht wie die Engländer und die Amerikaner da irgendwie Leute von uns hinschicken,
Bundeswehr und das haben wir ja besprochen, dass sie dann alle total aufgeregt
haben und Deutschland muss sich echt nicht wundern, wenn denen keiner mehr irgendwelche
Geheimnisse erzählt, wenn sie sich so in der Öffentlichkeit verhalten.
Also das hat natürlich die deutsche Öffentlichkeit auch nicht gecheckt,
aber der Kanzler hat sich einfach komplett zum Horst gemacht mit seiner Reaktion.
Jetzt kam aber der zweite Schritt von Macron, wo er im Prinzip gesagt hat,
wenn die Frontlinie bricht in der Ukraine, dann müssen wir auch über andere Maßnahmen nachdenken.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was er gesagt hat, aber im Kern hat er gesagt.
Wir können auch mal anfangen darüber nachzudenken, da mit Truppen reinzugehen.
Und das muss ja nicht die NATO sein.
Das kann ja jedes Land auch für sich alleine entscheiden.
Wenn Frankreich der Meinung ist, die Ukraine braucht jetzt mal konkrete militärische
Unterstützung durch das französische Militär, dann können sie das ja tun.
Damit wird kein NATO-Vertrag aktiviert, weil es ja kein Angriff auf Frankreich ist.
Aber so wie Frankreich irgendwie in Afrika seine Fronten aufmacht,
auch wenn das nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema ist und mit dem Ukraine-Konflikt
so mittelbar erstmal nichts zu tun hat,
können sie das natürlich auch in der Ukraine tun und genauso können das auch
Schweden und die Balken und können alle das machen.
Und wenn die dann da in der Ukraine von den Russen angegriffen werden,
dann ist das kein Verteidigungsfall für die EU und kein Verteidigungsfall für
die NATO, dann ist das deren Entscheidung.
Aber am Ende wäre es natürlich zu begrüßen, dass wir einen europäischen Move
haben und im Idealfall halt auch, dass die NATO-Staaten sich da einig sind.
Ich meine, dann kommt nochmal Türkei und Ungarn auch nochmal ins Spiel,
das ist sicherlich schwierig, von daher wird so eine bilaterale Aktivität eher
die wahrscheinliche sein.
Nein, aber es kann halt durchaus sein, dass Frankreich irgendwann an diesen
Punkt kommt und sagt, wir gehen da jetzt mit rein.
Wir machen da jetzt mit, weil wir können es uns nicht leisten,
dass Russland angreift.
Und dann stehen die anderen natürlich da und müssen die Frage beantworten,
was machen wir jetzt, wenn die Franzosen da sind? Machen wir jetzt nichts?
Oder was machen wir jetzt? Und das ist, glaube ich, die Debatte,
die sich jetzt gerade entwickelt.
Ja, also ich frage mich natürlich sozusagen realistisch, was Frankreich dort tun könnte.
Und gut, ich meine, Frankreich ist natürlich auch Atommacht so.
Also insofern lässt Frankreich da jetzt auch nicht so mit sich rumspringen wie
vielleicht andere Länder,
obwohl Deutschland tatsächlich großen Anteil auch an der französischen Atomstreitmacht hat.
Also Deutschland baut die Raketen im Prinzip, wo die Atomsprengköpfe und so.
Also Deutschland hat da dick seine Finger auch in der französischen nuklearen Abschreckung mit drin.
Aber davon mal ab.
Letztlich wäre wahrscheinlich realistisch einerseits bei der Flugabwehr zu helfen,
das wäre wahrscheinlich eine Sache.
Und wahrscheinlich, wenn es jetzt zu einem russischen Durchbruch käme in irgendeiner Art,
dass man wahrscheinlich am ehesten mit der Luftwaffe und mit Raketen irgendwie
direkt aus der Ferne eher eingreifen würde.
So, das könnte ich mir noch vorstellen.
Aber es ist natürlich alles eine Folge dessen, dass man die Ukraine so hat hängen lassen,
weil eigentlich will das niemand, dass jetzt Frankreich oder überhaupt irgendwelche
NATO-Länder direkt jetzt auf Russen schießen oder umgekehrt.
Weil das hat halt schon natürlich Potenzial, dann weiter zu eskalieren.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist das genau jetzt ein Symptom dessen,
dass wir auch seit Monaten oder seit Jahren reden.
Wenn man die Ukraine nicht hinreichend unterstützt, dass sie sich selber verteidigen kann.
Und die Russen dann auf dem Vormarsch sind,
dann werden wir in den Krieg zwangsläufig mit hineingezogen,
weil wir allein die Flüchtlingswellen, die das auslöst,
nicht tolerieren können von der ganzen humanitären Katastrophe und so. Folgendes.
Ich meine, wir haben ja jetzt schon Millionen von Ukrainern in den besetzten
Gebieten, die faktisch gegen die Ukraine und gegen die NATO-Interessen kämpfen.
Und das kann natürlich auch nicht in unserem Sinne sein, dass jetzt noch, weiß ich nicht,
10 oder 20 Millionen mehr Ukrainer plötzlich unter russische Kontrolle geraten
und dann quasi gezwungen werden,
gegen uns in den Krieg zu ziehen.
Und das ist halt, glaube ich, der Denkfehler, dem viele jetzt die Frieden wollen,
um jeden Preis erliegen.
Das sagen, indem man deeskaliert jetzt oder indem man die Ukraine hängen lässt,
dass das für mehr Sicherheit sorgt.
Aber das Gegenteil ist aus meiner Sicht der Fall.
Und diese Frankreich-Geschichte, glaube ich, gibt uns da Recht,
dass, wenn die Ukraine verliert, die Eskalation unvermeidlich ist.
Und es kommt ja noch was anderes dazu.
Also die Bedrohung durch Russland, also die unmittelbare militärische Bedrohung,
der dann noch größere Aufwand das Ganze im Rahmen zu halten.
Aber gehen wir jetzt mal auch einfach davon aus, dass wir an einem Punkt dann
sein werden, wo Russland dann auch wirklich besiegt ist. Es gibt ja keine Alternative dazu.
Es kann nichts anderes am Ende stehen, als dass Russland aus der Ukraine komplett
verscheucht wird. Alles andere ist politisch überhaupt nicht akzeptabel zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Und dann müssen wir das Land aufbauen.
Und mit jedem zerstörten Kraftwerk, mit jedem zerstörten Haus,
mit jedem Krankenhaus, mit jeder zerstörten Infrastruktur, mit jedem zerstörten
Staudamm wachsen die Kosten, um die Ukraine auf ein EU-Level zu bringen.
Und diesem Land eine Zukunft zu garantieren, die absolut erforderlich ist für
eine Stabilität an dieser Ostgrenze zu Russland, wachsen diese Kosten einfach
nochmal exponentiell an. Also es wird immer teurer.
Jedes bisschen zurückgehaltener Unterstützung muss zehnfach später bezahlt werden.
Ja, ja. Wobei, also aus meiner Sicht,
schätze ich das so ein,
dass es keinen, aber keinen klaren Weg gibt, jetzt die russischen Truppen militärisch
zu verdrängen oder zu vertreiben.
Also ich rechne nicht damit, dass Russland irgendwann tatsächlich faktisch die
Leute ausgehen oder die Munition ausgeht oder die Waffen ausgehen.
Also ich glaube, Russland könnte das jahrzehntelang auf dem aktuellen Level
tatsächlich fortsetzen,
jetzt rein materiell gesehen.
Das Problem ist aber, dass irgendwann man davon ausgehen kann,
der politische Wille in Russland erlahmen wird.
Weil wenn die Kosten zu hoch werden und die Fortschritte ausbleiben,
also sprich, ein Ausgang im Sinne jetzt des Westens wäre einer,
wo Russland dann sich in einer Situation befindet wie damals in Afghanistan.
Afghanistan, also Russland war jetzt auch in Afghanistan nicht besiegt,
aber die Stimmung zu Hause war halt irgendwann so, dass man keinen Bock mehr hatte.
Und aus meiner Sicht ist das der Punkt, wo man hinkommen muss,
dass Russland einfach anerkennt oder sieht.
Dass da nicht mehr zu holen ist und dass sie sich dann zurückziehen.
So, aber davon sind wir noch weit, weit, weit entfernt.
Auf lange Sicht natürlich jetzt, ich sag mal drei, vier, fünf Jahre oder so,
wäre es durchaus möglich,
die Ukraine dann so weit aufzurüsten, dass sie dann tatsächlich in der Lage
ist, dann wieder militärisch die Oberhand zu gewinnen und auch in die Offensive zu gehen.
Aber davon sind wir derzeit auch weit entfernt.
Das heißt, im Moment sieht es halt so aus, dass sich auf absehbare Zeit beide
Seiten weiter unter hohen Verlusten bekämpfen werden.
Also ich teile deine Einschätzung nicht, dass Russland das jetzt beliebig lange durchhalten kann.
Also würde es jetzt wirklich einen militärischen Druck geben von Europa aus
und vor allem von den Amerikanern aus.
Also wenn jetzt Amerika in diesen Krieg eintreten würde, dann...
Dann halten die das nicht zehn Jahre durch. Und die haben auch nicht,
ich meine allein die Panzermengen, die sie jetzt verbanden, man kann jetzt davon ausgehen,
dass ungefähr 50 Prozent der Panzer,
und vielleicht nur 20 Prozent ihrer Armat-Wickel, also je nach Kategorie ist
das so ein bisschen anders, aber bei den Panzern kann man glaube ich relativ
klar sagen, dass wir da so uns den 50 Prozent,
und zwar den besseren 50 Prozent ihres Bestandes annähern und sie sind nicht
in der Lage, auch mit ihrer maximal hochgefahrenen.
Kriegsproduktion, in der sie sich jetzt bereits befinden, das lange durchzuhalten.
Also Russland ist jetzt quasi in einem Kriegsmodus wirtschaftlich.
Die großen Firmen müssen Personal abgeben, damit die irgendwie an der Front kämpfen.
Die verlieren also am laufenden Meter Leute und da haben wir ja schon viel darüber
darüber gesprochen, was das heute schon für Probleme auslöst, Infrastruktur.
Man hat jetzt gerade diese riesigen Überschwemmungen gehabt in bestimmten Landesteilen,
dem sie einfach nichts entgegensetzen wollen oder können.
Die Korruption macht das Land kaputt und die Unternehmen verdienen auch kein Geld mehr.
Sogar Gazprom hat jetzt irgendwie das erste Mal seit 20 Jahren Verluste gemeldet
und zwar heftige Verluste.
Also da geht es sozusagen mal konkret in die andere Richtung.
Und wenn der ganze Öl- und Gassektor kein Geld mehr abwirft,
dann ist das Land auch nicht mehr in der Lage, diesen Krieg beliebig zu finanzieren.
Vielleicht schon nochmal ein bisschen länger theoretisch, aber irgendwann,
wie du schon richtig sagst, geht dann auch in der Bevölkerung der Deal irgendwann nicht mehr auf.
Weil dann funktioniert das halt eben auch mit dem Wohlstand in Moskau und in St.
Petersburg nicht mehr und das ist eigentlich das Einzige, worum es geht die ganze Zeit.
Ja, allerdings setzt Russland im Moment,
ich meine es ist schwer wirklich gute Zahlen zu bekommen, aber die letzte Schätzung, die ich hatte, ist,
dass der Krieg direkt Russland ungefähr 100 Milliarden Dollar im Jahr kostet,
also 300 Millionen am Tag.
Das sind so die Größenordnungen, was halt ungefähr 5% vom russischen Bruttoinlandsprodukt.
Im Zweiten Weltkrieg hatten verschiedene Länder dann die Rüstungsproduktion bis auf 50,
60 Prozent vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt hochgefahren.
Also das sind so die Grenzen einer volkswirtschaftlichen Belastbarkeit,
so ungefähr die Hälfte aller Ressourcen in den Krieg zu stecken.
Und davon ist Russland noch weit entfernt.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich glaube, dass auf dem bisherigen Niveau, was es bisher kostet,
Russland das dauerhaft durchhalten kann, rein wirtschaftlich betrachtet.
Eine andere Sache sind die Verluste an Menschenleben.
Das war auch im Afghanistan-Krieg, glaube ich, so ein Punkt,
wo es dann anfängt, was halt irgendwann auffällt.
Ja gut, aber im Afghanistan-Krieg waren es irgendwie 30.000,
die gestorben sind und 30.000 verlieren die jetzt mal pro Monat gerade.
Also das scheinen sie noch wegzuschlecken, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass das so eine beliebige Ressource ist, die man einfach so nach wie vor dort
reinwerfen kann. Ich meine auch das ganze Material.
Womit wollen sie denn dann irgendwann den Krieg nochmal führen,
wenn alle Panzer weg sind?
Also ich meine, wenn sie jetzt schon 50% losgeworden sind, die können nicht
so viele Panzer bauen, wie sie derzeit verbrauchen.
Also ich halte es schon für möglich, dass sie die Panzerproduktion jetzt speziell
bei Panzern hochfahren.
Man geht davon aus, oder sie behaupten, dass sie jetzt 100 Panzer im Monat neu
herstellen können, die Russen.
Das sind so die Zahlen, von denen die Rede ist.
Wobei man natürlich nicht weiß, sind das jetzt wirklich neue Panzer oder ist
das inklusive Refurbishment und Reparatur und sozusagen Modernisierung von Gerät,
was sie noch im Depot haben.
Wahrscheinlich spielt das irgendwie mit da rein. Auf der anderen Seite sind
jetzt 100 Panzer im Monat für ein Land wie Russland jetzt kein unüberwindliches Hindernis.
Sie haben die Rohstoffe, sie haben die Energie, sie haben ein bisschen Probleme
bei der technischen Ausrüstung, beispielsweise bei Nachtsichtgeräten und da
bauen sie halt minderwertigen Kram ein.
Aber mein Punkt ist, dass Russland durchaus in der Lage ist,
100 oder 200 Panzer im Monat tatsächlich zu produzieren irgendwann,
also wenn sie es wollen und Munition und anderes und damit auf einem Niveau
zumindest Waffen nachproduzieren können,
dass die Ukraine sie nicht einfach überrennt.
Kann, also sozusagen dem Zusammenbruch eigentlich abwenden können.
Rein jetzt materiell gesehen.
Ja, die Ukraine, ja. Aber halt nicht mehr als die Ukraine.
Und Russland würde heute schon schwer darunter leiden, wenn irgendwo noch an
einer ihrer Grenzen ein weiterer Konflikt entstehen würde.
Und das Land ist extrem vulnerable.
Also mir will das nicht so in den Kopf, dass sie das so mühelos schaffen.
Und nicht mühelos, sondern mit Folgen natürlich für Inflation und Warenversorgung
für auch den privaten Sektor und so.
Aber wie gesagt, die Größenordnungen sind jetzt noch nicht so,
dass sich, also Russland ist weit entfernt vom totalen Krieg.
Gut, also wir müssen das offen lassen, weil um ehrlich zu sein, wir wissen es nicht.
Also wir kennen diese Zahlen nicht und alle Zahlen, die veröffentlicht sind, sind halt von Russland.
Das heißt, die stimmen im Zweifelsfall sowieso nicht, beziehungsweise werden
so gar nicht herausgegeben.
Es sind alles nur Einschätzungen, Abschätzungen und wir wissen vor allem eins,
alle Einschätzungen in Bezug auf Russland zu Beginn dieses Krieges lagen auch weit daneben.
Und das Ganze eben vor dem Hintergrund eines möglichen Eintritts einer weiteren
Partei in diesen Krieg, glaube ich, sind diese Ressourcen dann aber auch sehr
schnell unter einem ganz anderen Druck.
Anyway, lass uns vielleicht nochmal zurück auf Europa kommen und wie sich Europa
jetzt sozusagen aufstellt, weil die These war ja, Russland kämpft weiter,
Ukraine darf nicht verlieren, alle haben jetzt so ein bisschen Schiss vor dieser doppelten Bedrohung.
Auf der einen Seite eine russische Front, die voran marschiert auf der einen
Seite und Trump im Rücken auf der anderen Seite.
Also diese Angst Amerika als großer Beschützer zu verlieren.
Die sozusagen auf Zuruf irgendwo reinfliegen und ihre Macht demonstrieren und
dann kann Europa weiterhin Gutes tun und Zelte bauen und von Friedensmissionen
träumen, wie Deutschland das halt ganz gerne macht.
Ich sehe, dass sich das in Europa ändert, nur eben noch in Deutschland nicht.
Also Frankreich haben wir jetzt schon besprochen, die skandinavischen Länder
ziehen ihren Support extrem an, Norwegen erhöht am laufenden Meter das Budget der Unterstützung,
Dänemark liefert mehr oder weniger schon seinen kompletten Militärbestand dorthin.
Also alle F-16, die komplette Artillerie, was sie haben.
Tschechien tut ja eine ganze Menge, da haben wir ja schon in der letzten Sendung drüber gesprochen.
Die baltischen Staaten reißen sich sowieso schon ein Bein aus.
Und man darf vor allem nicht vergessen, Polen rüstet mehr auf,
als die Ukraine an Unterstützung erhält.
Also allein Polen wird schon zu so einer Superpower und ich denke,
in dem Moment, wo Frankreich sagt, wir gehen ja jetzt mal rein,
da ist Polen dann auch nicht weit.
So und wenn Polen im Krieg mit Russland ist wird sich Deutschland dem sowieso nicht entziehen können.
Ja ich weiß, dass jetzt einige zuhören und sagen, oh mein Gott,
hier Pavel, Tim habt ihr überhaupt noch alle ihr redet ja hier den großen Krieg
herbei und wir wollen ja keinen dritten Weltkrieg haben,
also ich will das auch nicht Ja. Ich wollte das alles nicht.
Aber mir, ich kann nicht weiter in so einer Traumwelt leben,
wo wir uns denken, so, ja, wieso ist so hier 23 Grad in Berlin,
ist ja schön, ich kann den ganzen Tag in meinem Kaffee sitzen,
meinen Laptop aufklappen und irgendwie von der Zukunft träumen. Aber.
Mir misslingt es einfach, Europa nicht als Ganzes zu sehen.
Also für mich ist irgendwie diese Kleinstaaterei hat mir noch nie gepasst und
für mich fängt Europa an der Ukraine und an Polen und an den baltischen Staaten und Finnland an.
So, Russland ist für mich die Antithese zu dem,
was wir jetzt hier haben in ihrer ganzen imperialen Attitüde und in dem,
was Russland sozusagen für uns sein kann.
Ich meine Russland ist maximal so ein feuchter rechter Traum von Größe und Stärke,
wo aber irgendwie nichts dahinter ist. Der Kaiser hat irgendwie keine Kleider.
Ich identifiziere mich mit allem, was der Rest von Europa ist und für mich kann
es nur eine europäische Einheit geben.
Und insofern sehen wir uns als Europa, als westliches Modell konfrontiert mit
einem völlig durchdrehenden Russland, was leider.
Das tut mir ja sehr leid für die russischen Bürger, die es auch anders sehen,
aber die einfach frei drehen und die einfach in jeder Hinsicht so verhalten,
wie das Deutschland in den 30er Jahren getan hat.
Die wollen diesen Kontinent mit Krieg überziehen.
Die haben imperiale Ansprüche.
Im Fernsehen wird die ganze Zeit erzählt, wen sie jetzt als nächstes noch alles
ausradieren und bombardieren wollen und definieren sich ausschließlich über
so einen territorialen Gesamtanspruch,
dass sie irgendwie alles kontrollieren wollen.
Und das ist ja auch nicht nur in Europa so, es ist halt auch in Afrika so.
Und wo auch immer sie mitmischen, sie erzeugen einfach nur Ärger und Krieg und Gewalt.
Das ist halt einfach mal ein Fakt und dem müssen wir uns entgegenstellen.
So wie wir es bisher gemacht haben, funktioniert das leider nicht und das gehört
dann einfach dazu, dass wir jetzt einfach mal akzeptieren, dass Russland im
Krieg mit Europa ist. Und wir sind Europa.
Also sind wir da. Und dieses ganze Gerede mit man darf nichts eskalieren und
wir dürfen uns nicht in den Krieg hineinziehen lassen.
Sorry, wake up. Wir sind im Krieg.
Wir haben uns das nicht gewünscht und wir haben das auch nicht gewählt,
sondern das ist etwas, was Russland hier an die Tür getragen hat.
Aber das ist halt unsere Tür und dementsprechend müssen wir uns auch entsprechend
verhalten und das bedeutet natürlich leider eine Kriegsindustrie wieder in Wallung
zu kriegen, die in der Lage ist,
dem was Russland dort aufbietet etwas entgegen zu halten.
Und zwar nicht, weil ich Krieg geil finde, sondern einfach weil es nicht anders
geht, weil die Alternative ist Tod und Zerstörung und da habe ich jetzt ehrlich
gesagt gerade keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, da stimme ich absolut mit dir überein. Wobei, ich meine,
es ist alles immer irgendwie auf einem Spektrum.
Aber wir befinden uns in einem Stellvertreterkrieg auf jeden Fall, so mit Russland.
Das kann man glaube ich festhalten und das sieht auch Russland so und,
wir haben aber bisher vermeiden können dass dieser in einen heißen Krieg übergeht so also,
kalt.
Ist er nicht.
Nee, aber in einem heißen Krieg oder in einem direkten Krieg, sag ich mal,
zwischen NATO und Russland oder NATO-Ländern und Russland.
Also es ist nach wie vor ein stellvertretender Krieg. Die Ukrainer kämpfen,
die Ukrainer sterben so in erster Linie in diesem Krieg auf unserer Seite.
Ja, für uns.
Für uns, genau. Für sich natürlich auch,
aber das ist halt das Irrsinnige,
dass wir nicht mit allem, was wir können,
unterstützen und unterstützt haben, um eben genau dieses Szenario abzuwenden,
dass wir da mit Truppen rein müssen.
Was bisher zwar noch gelungen ist, aber was jetzt nicht garantiert ist,
aufgrund der aktuellen militärischen Entwicklung.
Aber ich sehe nach wie vor für keine Seite, weder für Russland noch für die
Ukraine, einen klaren Pfad,
den Konflikt militärisch zu klar zu entscheiden.
So den sehe ich im Moment nicht.
Also auch für Russland nicht.
Ich glaube aber auch, dass das gar nicht mal erforderlich ist.
Weil ich denke, dass Russland treibt diesen Konflikt derzeit vor allem deshalb
voran, weil sich der Westen,
einfach nicht entscheiden kann sich dem entgegenzustellen in dem Moment wo die
NATO sagen würde so Herr Putin,
Wir haben jetzt einfach langsam die Lust verloren und wir sind jetzt einfach nicht mehr bereit.
Mach dich jetzt mal auf was gefasst. Also in dem Moment, wo er Stärke spürt,
dann wird sich Russland auch zurückziehen.
Weil es ist ja nur der Ausblick darauf, dass Europa auch weiterhin nichts und
nicht genug tut, gut, die ihn überhaupt in die Lage versetzt zu glauben,
hier könnte noch etwas gewonnen werden.
Wir sind diejenigen, die Russland aktiv Hoffnung machen, mehr rauszuholen, als sie bisher haben.
Und in dem Moment, wo sich dieses Blatt wendet und wo einfach klar gesagt wird,
also nicht nur bis hierhin und nicht weiter,
sondern ab jetzt rückwärts, Ja, in dem Moment, wo sich diese Kräfte aufstellen
und wo man mal serious business macht,
in dem Moment muss Putin einfach, damit riskiert er quasi sein Leben,
seine Position und damit riskiert er auch jeden Rückhalt.
Weil in dem Moment, wo es halt einfach konkret gegen das russische Militär auf
russischem Gebiet geht und über nichts anderes müssen wir da reden,
dann kann er nur noch verlieren, weil er kann verlieren.
Atomwaffen nicht zum Einsatz bringen. In dem Moment, wo das auch nur.
Wo da auch nur irgendeine Bewegung ist, wird es einfach böse enden.
Das Angriffspotenzial existiert halt im Westen und das wissen die Russen auch.
Und dann können sie auch nichts gewinnen.
Klar, jetzt werden natürlich einige sagen, oh mein Gott, Tim,
hast du sie jetzt alle nicht mehr beisammen?
Jetzt redest du noch den Atomkrieg herbei, aber das Ding ist, keiner will Atomkrieg.
Auch die Russen wollen keinen Atomkrieg. Die wissen, was damit dann auf dem Spiel steht.
Das ist nicht so, dass die so verrückt sind, dass sie alles tun würden.
Sie sind nur so krass drauf, dass sie uns alles androhen, damit wir davor davonrennen.
Und diese Schisserei und diese Angst Die Angstmacherei, die hier Erfolg hat,
die ist es, was Russland den Raum gibt, überhaupt das Ganze noch voranzutreiben.
Die wissen, dass sie uns eigentlich militärisch total unterlegen sind.
Aber sie wissen leider auch, dass wir in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren,
wann auch immer Russland nach vorne marschiert ist, einfach einen Rückzieher gemacht haben.
Transnistrien? Kein Interesse jetzt.
Abrasien? Ja, Georgien, interessiert uns das nicht. Süd-Ossetien?
Ja, die waren ja schon in Abrasien. Und überall, wo Russland gesagt hat,
das ist meins, so Krim, war dann immer so Du-Du-Du.
Und an das Du-Du-Du haben die sich halt einfach gewöhnt. Die gehen davon aus,
dass wir ihnen am Ende dann die Ukraine halt geben.
So, ah ja, Donetsk und so weiter, ist ja eh alles kaputt, was wollt ihr damit
noch groß, dann ziehen wir jetzt hier mal eine Linie und dann ist ja Frieden,
in Anführungsstrichen.
Und deswegen...
Deswegen marschieren die immer weiter, weil sie einfach zu keinem Zeitpunkt
irgendwann mal gesagt bekommen haben, so nö, das war es jetzt,
ihr zieht euch jetzt mal zurück, or else.
Und weil das halt nicht stattfindet, haben wir diesen Salat.
Also es ist halt einfach diese Appeasement-Politik, die schon gegen Hitler nicht
funktioniert hat, funktioniert halt hier auch nicht.
Und am Ende ist es auch so, da kann man ja auch Russland noch irgendwie toll
finden und die Kultur und was weiß ich und unsere europäischen Freunde oder
wie auch immer man so zu Russland steht.
Wenn man irgendwie auch für Russland auch nur ein Funken was im Herzen spürt,
was bei mir jetzt nicht so ausgeprägt ist, aber kann ja sein,
dann ist eigentlich eine Niederlage das Beste, was Russland passieren kann.
Eine Niederlage in der Ukraine ist das einzige, was dazu führen wird,
dass diese Gesellschaft in irgendeiner Form wieder auf die Füße kommen kann.
Weil sie nur dadurch gezeigt bekommt, okay wir fahren hier mit so einem Volldiktator
im Hitler-Modus, fahren wir einfach nicht gut, das bringt uns nichts,
wir brauchen was anderes.
Und natürlich wird dann die Nachfolge von Putin irgendwas weirdes sein und wird
dieses Land irgendwie die merkwürdigsten Wege finden, aber sie wird halt dann
ihren Kurs ändern müssen.
Also alle großen Imperien sind erst klar gekommen, nachdem sie mal ordentlich
eins auf die Mütze bekommen haben. Das gilt für alle.
Das gilt für Frankreich, das gilt für Deutschland, das gilt für UK.
Ich meine, wir haben alle mal total frei gedreht und waren der Meinung,
was kostet die Welt, gibt alles her, hier Afrika, alles unser,
Asien, wir müssen da irgendwo in den Philippinen und was weiß ich.
Also ich meine, Europa hat die ganze Welt mit Kriegen überzogen und jedes Land,
was so eine halbwegs militärische Größe hat, hat seine imperialen Träume gehabt
und war dann irgendwann nicht mehr aufzuhalten.
So lange, bis es geknallt hat. So lange, bis halt irgendjemand sich entgegengestellt
hat und gesagt hat, Leute, das war's jetzt.
Und dann fing man an wirklich mal von Weltfrieden zu reden, aber bis dahin halt
nicht und das ist halt die Lektion, die Russland einfach nicht gelernt hat.
Ja, ich stimme da mit dir bei, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß ist,
dass Putin oder auch die russische Führung als Ganzes auf Druck,
auf Gewalt tatsächlich reagiert und im Zweifelsfall eher dann einen Rückzieher macht,
wenn ihre Macht gefährdet ist.
So und ja, aber wie gesagt, Russland ist nicht voll committed bisher.
Sondern nur bestenfalls, also noch nicht mal halb committed für diesen Krieg,
sondern die versuchen das natürlich hochzufahren, aber Putin versucht gleichzeitig
nicht zu Hause für zu viel Unruhe zu sorgen.
Also Putin sitzt so ein bisschen in der Klemme, wie auch alle Populisten,
dass er irgendwo schon auch das Volk zufriedenstellen muss oder zumindest nicht
allzu unzufrieden machen darf.
Und da gibt es eben Grenzen.
Und die kennt Putin auch ganz gut und bisher ist es ihm durchaus gut gelungen
da zu lavieren, auch mit immer ein.
Auch mit der Rekrutierung und so sind sie eher dann den milderen Weg gegangen,
nachdem sie gesehen haben, dass die erste, diese Zwangsrekrutierungswelle,
die sie irgendwann gemacht haben, gar nicht gut angekommen ist.
Machen sie es seitdem mit Geld halt recht erfolgreich, Leute für den Krieg zu gewinnen.
Aber sie könnten halt auch anders.
Das ist einfach nur mein Punkt. Also
Russland hat noch eine Menge Eskalationspotenzial und der Westen auch.
Und im Moment scheint es mir so zu sein, dass man sich im Westen und in Russland
so ein bisschen arrangiert hat mit der Situation und eigentlich nicht möchte,
gerade dass die zu schnell zu sehr in eine Richtung kippt.
Ja, das wird dann halt nur immer teurer werden. Lass uns mal zum Ausklang nochmal
kurz, auch wenn wir jetzt schon über so viele Metathemen gesprochen haben,
vielleicht nochmal kurz,
auf die potenziellen, ich mag den Begriff gar nicht, Game Changer,
was konkret an Technik jetzt gerade am Start ist, was unter Umständen diesen
Krieg als nächstes nennenswert beeinflussen könnte.
Weil es ist tatsächlich eben diese Militärtechnik, die jetzt die Entscheidung
bringen kann. Das ist nun mal einfach so.
Wir hatten jetzt schon diese Attackams erwähnt. Vielleicht nochmal,
wer das nicht so ganz im Kopf hat, was das genau ist.
Also sehr erfolgreich, vielleicht das erfolgreichste Militärinstrument,
Was die Ukraine erhalten hat im ganzen Krieg sind diese HIMARS,
Multiple Rocket Launchers oder wie heißt nochmal gleich die...
Version, die in der Bundeswehr da zum Einsatz kommt, die kompatibel ist.
Mars.
Mars nennen die das genau. Es gab noch irgendwas mit einer Nummer.
Aber generell werden die einfach als HIMARS bezeichnet. Das sind so,
mobile Abschussstationen, die eben hochpräzise sind und die normalerweise so
ein 6er Set an Raketen losschicken können.
Dann gibt es noch die mit mit 6, die haben glaube ich die mit Rad und ich glaube
die Deutschen haben dann diese Kettenfahrzeugvariante, die nochmal das Doppelte
haben, irgendwie sowas.
Aber die sind alle kompatibel mit der Munition.
Und dort konnten halt eben bisher diese Gott, die ganzen Abkürzungen,
wie heißt nochmal gleich die Munition, die derzeit da, die Gimlas, genau.
GLMRS-Systeme, die halt dann irgendwie 100 Kilometer weit schießen können oder
80 oder sowas. Und die aber super präzise sind. Das ist halt das Ding.
Einmaß kann super präzise abfeuern,
also wenn man wirklich eine genaue Zielkoordinate haben, die treffen.
So, jetzt gibt es aber eben noch diese Long Range Munition, die eben nochmal
sehr viel mehr Sprengkraft hat und die dann mit demselben Launcher abgeschossen werden kann,
aber dann nutzt man von diesen sechs Fächern nur eins.
Und das sind diese Attack-Ams, die sind halt sehr viel teurer als die andere
Munition, macht aber eben sehr viel mehr kaputt und kann eben auch nochmal sehr viel weiter fliegen.
Gibt es ja eben in zwei Varianten und mit der weitesten möglichen Variante,
die jetzt allegedly eben von den USA auch geliefert wird und abgeschossen werden
darf bis zu 300 Kilometer.
Also das ist jetzt sozusagen das, was kommt und es gibt jetzt in den letzten
Tagen schon vermehrte Angriffe, wo man relativ klar sagen kann,
okay, das ist jetzt auch mit Attackams gemacht worden.
Nachdem da also lange Zeit nichts passiert ist, gab es jetzt Angriffe auf Truppkonzentrationen
ziemlich weit hinter der Frontlinie und wir hatten ja schon vor Monaten schon
mal Angriffe dann auch auf Hubschrauberstandorte gesehen und so weiter.
Also das ist schon eine Waffe, die einiges erreichen kann, muss man jetzt mal schauen.
Ob sie dann auch für die Kerchbrücke zum Einsatz kommen kann und wird,
ist glaube ich ein bisschen offen, aber es ist denkbar.
Es ist denkbar, dass sollte es wirklich mal einen konzertierten Angriff geben
auf diese Brücke, dann wäre es vorstellbar, dass auch die Attackams dort eine Rolle spielen.
Taurus gibt es ja nicht. Deswegen wäre das sozusagen eine Option.
Viele Leute erwarten das, aber mal gucken, ob das wirklich passieren wird.
Ja, also die Schwierigkeit mit den Attackams ist, sie sind auch nicht ganz unproblematisch
oder eignen sich auch nicht für alles besonders gut.
Also die gibt es halt in drei Varianten im Wesentlichen. So die M39,
also Block 1, und dann die haben halt,
nur eine Genauigkeit von ungefähr 250 Metern.
Also die haben noch nicht mal GPS drin,
die haben nur Trägheitsnavigation und sind nicht besonders genau und haben deswegen aber,
sind das Cluster-Gefechtsköpfe mit 950 Stück Submunition.
Deswegen ist das auch nicht so schlimm.
Wenn die nicht genau treffen, weil die ohnehin einen größeren Umkreis für Verwüstung sorgen.
Wie man jetzt auch gerade gesehen hat.
Ja, der Block 1A hat halt zusätzlich auch noch GPS und auch Submunition,
ist aber deutlich kleiner und leichter und dafür etwas genauer und unter 100 Metern.
Diese beiden Varianten eignen sich aber jetzt nicht besonders für den Angriff der Kertschbrücke,
weil das ist mehr so für Luftabwehrstellungen gegen Personal und so weiter. Und die...
Allerneuste Variante, die M57, die hat so eine Genauigkeit von 10 bis 20 Metern
und die hat dann so einen Penetrationsgefechtskopf.
Das wäre also, wenn, dann bräuchte man diese Variante für die Kertschbrücke.
Aber mit 10 bis 20 Metern Genauigkeit ist es halt auch nicht ideal.
Also idealerweise hätte man da dann schon eine Taurus, die man dann in einen
der Pfeiler hineinfliegt, würde wahrscheinlich besser funktionieren.
Aber ja, wie du schon richtig sagst, ausgeschlossen ist es nicht.
Aber wenn, dann bräuchten sie halt die M57-Variante, die neueste Attackums-Variante,
wenn sie damit die Kerchbrücke angreifen wollen.
Bisher haben sie offensichtlich Angriffe mit Attackams durchgeführt in der Nähe
der Kertschbrücke auf Luftabwehrstellungen.
Also haben da wohl irgendein S-300-System nahe der Kertschbrücke mit Attackams zerstört.
Und haben wohl jetzt auch gerade in den letzten Tagen erst mehrere Trainingsplätze angegriffen,
wo so russische Truppen ausgebildet wurden und wo man davon ausgeht,
dass da mehrere hundert russische Soldaten den Tod gefunden haben könnten bei diesen Angriffen.
Und vorher gab es auch noch Angriffe auf Flugplätze, die wohl auch mit Attackams
durchgeführt wurden und ähm.
Es wurden auch Attackams teilweise so pro Angriff drei Stück und so eingesetzt,
sodass man davon ausgehen kann,
dass die Ukraine die auch in größerer Zahl erwartet, weil wenn sie nur ein paar
Dutzend davon erwarten würden,
dann würden sie nicht gleich drei Stück in einen Angriff auf Truppen packen.
Also von daher ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass die USA wahrscheinlich einen
Großteil ihres Bestands oder zumindest Hunderte von den Attackams liefern werden.
Das ist so die Größenordnung, von der auszugehen ist.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist halt auch alter Kram mittlerweile.
Also es ist, ich meine,
der Block 1 wurde 1991 eingeführt, das ist also auch über 30 Jahre alte Technologie und die neueste.
Die M57 wurde 2003 eingeführt, hat also auch schon 21 Jahre auf dem Buckel.
Und ist, was Genauigkeit angeht und was die Zielnavigation angeht und so eigentlich
nicht mehr State of the Art.
Weshalb die Amerikaner die ja auch ersetzen wollen.
Allerdings, die Russen haben Panik, gerade wegen Attackers.
Ja, das kann denen schon schaden. Dass die neueste Technik nicht immer die beste
ist, das haben ja diese GLSDB-Munitionsdinger wiederum gezeigt in den letzten Wochen.
Wir hatten ja mehrfach davon berichtet, dass das so eine neue Munitionsoption
ist, die die Ukraine bekommen soll, die dann aber ewig nicht geliefert werden konnte.
Also es sollte, glaube ich, im letzten Sommer schon soweit sein.
Zwischendurch kam es wohl. Also ich rede von diesen GLS-DB, das sind diese Small
Diameter Bombs, also Gleitskits für tumbe Munition.
Also man macht sozusagen nochmal so ein Harness um bestehende günstige Munition
drum und dann kriegen die Flügelchen
und können weiter fliegen und sollen angeblich ganz toll treffen.
Das war sozusagen das Versprechen und tatsächlich nutzen die Russen ja genau
so eine Technik eben derzeit massiv ein mit großen Bomben, so Gleitbomben.
Und das war also jetzt hier eher für kleine Sprengköpfe gedacht,
aber das scheint nicht so gut zu funktionieren.
Also man hat sich wohl beim Testen in den USA im Wesentlichen auf Sicherheit beschränkt.
Also sicherzustellen, dass die Dinger safe sind im Handling und auch nicht irgendwo
hinfliegen, wo sie nicht hin sollen.
Aber weshalb sie in der Praxis sich als Flop herausgestellt haben,
ist, dass die Kombination aus kleinem Sprengkopf,
nämlich nur 36 Kilogramm, der ist nur effektiv, wenn die GLSDB bis zum Ende hin auch GPS hat.
Und damit die 1-3 Meter Genauigkeit erreicht.
Aber die kriegt sie halt nur mit GPS hin.
Wenn das GPS gestört ist, was praktisch regelmäßig der Fall ist,
mittlerweile an der Front,
schafft das Trägheitsnavigationssystem nur 30-50 Meter Genauigkeit.
Das ist jetzt kein Problem, wenn du eine 500 oder 1000 Kilo Bombe abwirfst.
Die hat einen Wirkungsradius je nachdem von Hunderten von Metern,
wo sie Zerstörungen anrichtet.
Aber wenn du nur so einen 36 Kilo Sprengkopf hast und der fliegt 30 Meter daneben,
dann ist nicht viel gewesen.
Und Hintergrund ist wohl, dass die SDB1,
die sie gewählt haben, nämlich diese GBU-39B-Gleitbombe, die wurde 2007 als
Provisorium eingeführt.
Also man wusste so ein bisschen um die Probleme, aber man brauchte da was und
in denen auch Einsätzen, in denen
man sich befand, nämlich wo man absolute Luftüberlegenheit hat und so,
war das jetzt kein Problem.
Aber für diesen Einsatzzweck hier jetzt,
ja, zeigt sich, dass diese Version 1,
diese SDP 1 einfach nicht in einem gestörten GPS-Umfeld gut klarkommt.
Und es gibt da seit 2015 auch deswegen einen Nachfolger, SDP-2.
Der hat eben auch noch Radar an Bord und Thermal Imaging und kann auch ohne
GPS genau treffen und hat auch einen etwas größeren Sprengkopf.
Also es ist auch wieder so ein Beispiel, wo die USA eigentlich die Technologie
und die Waffen haben, die besser funktionieren würden, aber Ukraine halt irgendwie
jetzt mit dem alten Kram auskommen muss,
der nur ein Provisorium hat.
War und das ja, war wohl in dem Fall jetzt ein Flop und interessant ist eben
auch noch, dass jetzt dann die Debatte ist,
weil verschiedene andere Länder haben jetzt auch GLSDB bestellt und die sind
jetzt nicht so begeistert, aber die USA selber ficht das jetzt nicht großartig an,
weil die ja die eh ausgemustert haben und sowieso,
SDB2s jetzt eh benutzen, deswegen Deswegen finden die das jetzt nicht so schlimm,
dass die SDB 1 nicht so gut funktioniert, weil das eh klar war.
Das ist so ein bisschen leider die nicht so erfreuliche GLSDB-Geschichte.
Ja, gut. Dafür funktionieren andere Sachen ganz gut, wie es den Eindruck hat,
nämlich das ganze Drohnenprogramm.
Vielleicht nochmal, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das letzte Mal schon erwähnt haben.
Also generell haben wir jetzt leider im Eingang,
glaube ich, nochmal diese ganzen fortwährenden Angriffe auf die Gas- und Ölinfrastruktur
und Fabriken gar nicht nochmal explizit erwähnt. Da hatten wir aber in der letzten
Sendung schon drüber berichtet.
Das läuft auch weiterhin und der Effekt ist halt auch spürbar.
Soviel auch nochmal zum Thema, wie lang kann Russland das so durchhalten.
Ich meine, der Großteil des Staats...
Und Budgets, also die Haupteinnahmequelle Russlands ist halt Öl und Gas.
Ist halt einfach so. Macht 50 Prozent aus.
Und die Ukraine greift mit ihren Drohnen, die sie jetzt bauen in allen Formen und Varianten.
Und letztes Mal haben wir da glaube ich nur drüber gemunkelt,
aber ich glaube mittlerweile gibt es da auch eine Bestätigung dafür,
dass dieses Leitflugzeug, was schon ewig in der Ukraine gibt,
tatsächlich zu einer Drohne umgebaut wird.
Also die fliegen im Prinzip so Cessna-Größe, ein bisschen kleiner ist es schon
noch, so eine halbe Cessna-Flugzeuge sozusagen nach Russland rein und dadurch,
dass Russland einfach all seine ganzen Flugabwehrsysteme irgendwie um die Ukraine
herum im Einsatz hat an der Front,
schaffen sie es trotzdem da irgendwie dran vorbeizukommen und fliegen mittlerweile
bis zu 1000 Kilometer ins Land rein. Nein.
Und die Ukraine hat jetzt aber auch selber gesagt, dass sie jetzt auch schon
Drohnen haben, die bis zu 3300 Kilometer Reichweite haben.
Das heißt, sie sind in der Lage wirklich so ziemlich jede Ölraffinerie zu erreichen
und sie haben jetzt glaube ich auch schon mehr als die Hälfte irgendwie in irgendeiner
Form schon mal beschädigt bis hin zu Zerstörungen,
die halt dazu führen, dass sie teilweise schon seit Wochen nichts mehr produzieren.
Und ich hatte letztes Mal auch gesagt, das wurde in den Kommentaren dann nochmal
kommentiert, dass es ja, ich
hatte glaube ich gesagt, dass es irgendwie 10-12% Einbruch im Export gab.
Tatsächlich hieß es dann bis dahin erstmal nur in der Produktion,
stimmt auch, aber mittlerweile gibt es auch Berichte, dass das eben auch konkret
auf die Exporteinnahmen sich entsprechend auswirkt.
Also dass schon 20 Prozent ungefähr der Exporteinnahmen einbrechen.
Und die Preise steigen, Dieselpreise steigen innerhalb Russlands.
Teilweise wird schon reimportiert aus Weißrussland, also dass Russland mal Sprit importiert.
Ich will das nochmal kurz betonen, weil das halt so ein Punkt ist,
wo man gar nicht so gut vorhersagen kann.
Also ich denke, dass Russland an vielen Stellen sehr angreifbar ist und dass
die Ukraine hier auf jeden Fall so einen nervösen Punkt getroffen hat und mit
diesem Drohnenprogramm weiterhin hier Fortschritte erzielt.
Genauso wie im Schwarzen Meer.
Schiffe alle ins Kaspische Meer verlagern.
Aber was ja noch ansteht jetzt, ist die Lieferung von F-16-Kampfflugzeugen.
Und das sollte man, glaube ich, nochmal ein bisschen klar machen,
was das jetzt eigentlich für Implikationen hat und warum eigentlich die Ukraine
die ganze Zeit nach diesen F-16s geschrien hat.
Das hat nämlich Also erstmal ist glaube ich, die F-16 ist so ein bisschen das
aktuelle westliche Universalkampfflugzeug.
Das existiert in großen Mengen, das ist viel produziert worden.
Mit der F-16 kann man so ziemlich jede Rakete,
also nahezu jede Rakete, die derzeit so im westlichen Portfolio ist,
die man an Flugzeuge ranhängen kann, kann man da ranhängen.
Also mag ein paar Sachen geben, die nur an anderen Flugzeugen sind,
aber so im Wesentlichen von dem verfügbaren Portfolio kann man so den Großteil
dort zum Einsatz bringen.
Das heißt sowohl was jetzt Verteidigung betrifft, also anfliegende Cruise Missiles
könnten, nachdem sie detektiert wurden, von einer F-16 abgeschossen werden,
wenn sie entsprechend ausgerüstet ist.
Das ist sicherlich eine der Aufgaben, die auch den F-16s, die jetzt schon geliefert
worden sind oder sich gerade in Lieferung befinden in der Ukraine,
also es heißt jetzt so um Mai, Juni herum,
Wir stehen jetzt so kurz vor der Phase, wo wir wahrscheinlich diese Flugzeuge
dann auch irgendwann im Einsatz sehen werden.
Die kommen bald wirklich.
Sie kommen bald wirklich, genau, it's coming. Und ich gehe nicht davon aus,
dass die Ukraine diese Flugzeuge sofort zum Angriff an der Front verwenden wird,
sondern die werden erstmal ihre Erfahrungen sammeln und sie werden sie erstmal
dafür einsetzen, was sie derzeit am dringendsten brauchen und das ist halt Luftabwehr.
Und halt ein Air-to-Air-Verteidigungssystem zu haben ist natürlich sehr viel
flexibler als ein Ground-to-Air-System.
Also die Patches, alles super und so weiter, aber da wo die nicht stehen können,
die halt auch nicht verteidigen.
Und die F-16, die ist halt flexibler, die kann halt schnell starten und kann
hochfliegen und kann halt anrauschende Raketen,
die man vielleicht schon eine halbe Stunde vorher in der Luft irgendwo gesehen
hat durch Radar, entsprechend verteidigen.
Ja, also Cruise Missiles vor allem so. Und die F-16 hat auch ein sehr ordentliches Radar.
Das heißt, sie ist auch in der Lage, dann eben mit ihrem eigenen Radar Ziele
aus über 100 Kilometern.
Zu erfassen und zu tracken. Und ja, also das ist sicherlich dann ein großes Asset.
Aber die andere Seite ist, dass natürlich die F-16 dann ein primäres Ziel dann
auch für russische Raketenangriffe sein wird.
Also sie werden dann auch versuchen, natürlich allein schon aus Publicity-Gründen die zu zerstören.
Das heißt, da wird sicherlich die Ukraine auch einiges an Aufwand treiben müssen,
um sowohl die Flugzeuge als auch die Support-Infrastruktur dann auch zu schützen.
So vor russischen Raketenangriffen vor allem.
Aber ich meine, sie haben es ja auch geschafft, von den wenigen Flugzeugen,
die sie ja von Anfang an hatten, sind ja auch noch welche übrig.
Also es ist ja auch bisher gelungen, da Schutzmaß natürlich auch einiges abgeschossen
worden, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so undenkbar, dass es gelungen ist.
Aber die F-16 braucht natürlich auch erheblich Ground Support.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem. Im Gegensatz zur Grippen,
wo du irgendwie an einer Straße die wieder aufmunitionieren kannst und auch
die derzeitigen russischen Modelle, die sie fliegen, sind da ein bisschen robuster als die F-16.
Die ist halt schon ein bisschen empfindlich, auch mit ihrem,
also du brauchst halt vor allem eine Start- und Landebahn, die halt möglichst wenig,
ja wie es so schön heißt, foreign debris haben, weil mit ihrem Ansaugtrakt,
der direkt vorne unter der Spitze liegt,
wird da leicht halt Zeugs angesaugt, was dann auf der Start- oder Landebahn
liegt zum Beispiel. Vielen Dank.
Und da ist die F-16 also auch etwas empfindlicher einfach. Das ist halt schon Hightech.
Und insofern warten, glaube ich, alle gespannt darauf, wie das dann in der Praxis
aussehen wird, wie sich die F-16 in dem Umfeld tatsächlich bewähren wird.
Aber auf jeden Fall besser als gar nichts.
Ob das sie allerdings jetzt die komplette Wende bringen wird,
dazu sind wahrscheinlich die Stückzahlen auch wieder nicht ausreichend.
Wenn sie jetzt 500 Stück bekommen würden davon, sähe das anders aus.
Aber es liegt ja eher in der Größenordnung von ein paar Dutzend Flugzeugen, die sie tatsächlich...
Ja, zumindest derzeit. Da ist halt viel zu holen.
Ich denke, wenn du da jetzt 100 Flugzeuge hinschicken würdest,
die könnten sie auch gar nicht alle betreiben.
Also hier hätten nicht die Piloten, hier hätten nicht den Ground Support,
die Speicher, die sicheren Bunker für die Dinger. Also das muss ja auch alles noch gebaut werden.
Also das wird sich aufbauen. Ich erinnere mich noch an eine Zahl,
dass irgendwie so 150 von den Dingern ausreichen würden, um das gesamte Gebiet
der Ukraine zu beschützen.
Mal gucken, vielleicht kommen wir da ja auch noch hin. Jetzt muss halt erstmal
gezeigt werden, dass die Dinger auch wirklich zum Einsatz kommen.
Ja.
Ja, ich denke, jetzt sollte man dann auch mal langsam das so zusammenfalten hier.
Wir hatten noch einen Punkt, den wir noch nicht erwähnt hatten,
nämlich die Personalprobleme in der Ukraine.
Ich glaube, wir hatten in der letzten Sendung schon erwähnt,
dass da jetzt in der Ukraine das Rekrutierungsalter jetzt gesenkt wurde auf 25.
Bisher wurden ja erst ab 1927, glaube ich, die Männer eingezogen.
Und in dem Zusammenhang aber kam halt auf,
auch dass 650.000 Männer in dem wehrtauglichen Alter die Ukraine verlassen haben.
Also auch im Prinzip ein Potenzial darstellen, das noch erschlossen werden könnte,
ein Rekrutierungspotenzial.
Aber da scheint man jetzt noch etwas behutsam vorgehen zu wollen.
Oder was hast du darüber gehört?
Ja, das Thema kam ja nochmal auf, weil ich glaube Litauen,
Polen und mittlerweile auch Tschechien sich zu diesem Thema dahingehend geäußert
haben, dass sie gesagt haben,
okay, wir haben jetzt hier eine Menge Ukrainer, also Männer, die in diesem Alter,
also nicht Alter im Sinne von sehr jung, sondern generell 27 bis bis,
ich weiß nicht, ein paarundfünfzig,
die bei uns jetzt quasi leben,
wir würden die halt bei Bedarf auch zurückschicken.
Also ihnen keinen weiteren Aufenthalt sozusagen gewähren, wenn denn die Ukraine das so wünscht.
Und derzeit wünscht die Ukraine sich zwar mit Sicherheit, dass Leute zurückkommen
und sagen, ich helfe jetzt mit. Aber...
Ähm, sie sind noch nicht bereit, jetzt hier den Partnern zu sagen,
macht das jetzt mal bitte auf Zwang und dann nehmen wir euch die ab.
Also das ist für uns natürlich ein bisschen schwer nachzuvollziehen,
was da jetzt die Motivation ist und die innenpolitische Situation,
aber das ist so derzeit das Ding. So oder so haben sie aber einfach ein Personalproblem.
Also es ist halt einfach, die Leute an der Front sind ausgekämpft und es gibt
einfach nicht genug Leute, um das Potenzial dann aufzufüllen.
Ja, ein Problem, was ich da auch sehe, ist, dass wenn, dann müsste das auf europäischer
Ebene entschieden werden,
weil wenn da jetzt Einzelländer vorpreschen, würde das wieder massive Migrationsbewegungen
von wehrpflichtigen Ukrainern auslösen, die dann, was weiß ich,
nach Ungarn oder nach Deutschland oder wo auch immer sie dann nicht befürchten
müssen, zurückgeschickt zu werden.
Und ich glaube, das will man auch nicht unbedingt gerade.
Das will die Ukraine vielleicht auch nicht aufmachen, das Fass,
weil das halt für Unruhe im Westen sorgen könnte,
wenn plötzlich irgendwie da Hunderttausende von ukrainischen Männern plötzlich
anfangen umzuziehen. Das ist nicht gut.
Das mag ein Aspekt sein, aber ich glaube, das ist dann eher so ein EU-internes
politisches Problem und nichts, worüber Ukraine primär nachdenkt.
Aber, naja, also ich glaube, man denkt schon in der Ukraine auch darüber nach,
welche Probleme man in der EU verursacht an der Stelle. Kann auch sein, ja.
Und, ja, Ja, man hat halt, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Millionen es insgesamt
sind, die jetzt noch im Westen gerade Unterschlupf gefunden haben.
Aber ich glaube, man will diese Situation nicht unnötig anheizen,
dass es da Probleme gibt.
Weil bisher scheint es so zu sein, dass die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge eigentlich
keine allzu großen Probleme zu machen scheinen. in der Öffentlichkeit.
Es ist jetzt keine Ressentiments bekannt oder so.
Ja, ja.
So viel von uns zur aktuellen Situation in diesem Konflikt. Es bleibt viel zu
diskutieren. Man merkt es immer wieder.
Ich denke immer so, jetzt haben wir ja nur einen Monat und es ist ja eigentlich nicht viel passiert.
Und dann sitzen wir da trotzdem und haben irgendwie zwei Stunden durchgequatscht.
Aber so ist es halt.
Ich hoffe, da war was für euch dabei und ihr könnt auch nachvollziehen,
aus welchem Betrachtungswinkel wir hier so zu unseren Schlüssen kommen.
Es ist schon klar, dass wir hier eine mittlerweile, glaube ich,
eine relativ entschlossene Grundhaltung an den Tag legen, die nicht unbedingt
jetzt so jedem in den Kram passt und wo es sicherlich auch noch andere Meinungen gibt.
Aber naja, so sehe ich das und du auch.
Ja, ich habe vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Verständnis für die pazifistische
Position oder für die, ich sag mal, Nicht-Eskalations-Position,
obwohl ich sie für falsch halte.
Aber ich bin halt nur zu 95% davon überzeugt, dass ich recht habe,
während du glaube ich zu 100% überzeugt bist.
Das würde ich so nicht unterschreiben, weil ich generell immer auch der Meinung
bin, ich kann auch komplett falsch liegen.
Das ist nicht so der Punkt, aber das ist so das, was mein Gefühl mir sagt,
was derzeit sozusagen die richtige Haltung wäre.
Ich sehe halt einfach nicht, dass sich das Problem von alleine löst und auf
gar keinen Fall löst sich das Problem durch Aktivitäten von Russland.
Bleiben halt nur noch wir und die Ukraine kann es ohne uns alleine nicht lösen,
also kommen wir da mit dem Thema einfach nicht dran vorbei.
So, es ist halt einfach, man kann sich alles wünschen, aber Realpolitik ist
halt kein Wünsch dir was, sondern man muss halt einfach auf die Fakten schauen
und das ist das, was wir versuchen hier zu tun. Naja.
Gut, ich hoffe, das hat euch dann weitergeholfen. Dann können wir uns halt verabschieden, oder?
Ja.
Machen wir das.
Und dann, je nachdem, irgendwie, was so in den nächsten Wochen passiert.
Wahrscheinlich, wir sind ja jetzt in so einem Rhythmus von, ich sag mal,
drei bis vier Wochen ungefähr jetzt mit unseren Sendungen.
Und ich denke, den werden wir auch beibehalten, wahrscheinlich erst mal.
Was da jetzt passiert, wenn da irgendwas ganz monumental ist.
Alright, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Okay. Und bis bald. Ciao.
Mach's gut. Ciao.